whose life with what's up in surrett I
don't have a lot to say about that
actually it's good right now for that
Instagram tik-tok live tick-tock what's
good Twitter live good baby
cool live we're fully live facebooking
and Linkedin YouTube now yeah awesome
everything's life good what's up
everybody
how's everybody doing today I'm in a
really really good mood I thought it
would be a really good idea for me to do
a bunch of Q&A and here's how we're
gonna do the QA if you want to ask a
question about sports cards you can text
me the question at two one two nine
three one five seven three one for
everybody who is Manning the cameras if
you want to pin that phone number to the
top real quick or repeat it or whatever
you're planning on doing two one two
nine three one five seven three one two
one two nine three one five seven three
one that sticker would be good because I
want to talk about that so yeah so I'm
gonna answer about sports questions let
me get a little bit of a rant out on
what's been going on a little history of
how I got here and then we'll just go
into full Q&A obviously I'm extremely
excited about sports cards as he been
able to tell with uh with my content
over the last 60 90 days especially it
all kind of started well it all kind of
started in 1986 from 1986 to 1994 I was
wildly in the sports card game I did
sports card shows in a lot of weekends
in in eighth grade and then high school
then I started working in the store a
lot my dad's liquor store so I did less
but I was constantly in that game I had
a blip of a comeback in 2003 because I
thought the bran James was a
generational talent and so I bought a
ton of bo3 FLIR
and unfortunately it was a little guy
you know but done like got busy and and
didn't really go as hard all the way
through the tops chrome or some of the
other stuff as I wanted to but we did
that and then two years ago two years
ago it started getting really real for
me my little guy was starting to get
into it and his friends and it kind of
got on my radar obviously a huge
connection boy it's one of my macro
pieces there's a lot of macro theses
that made me decide to call my friends
to august's ago and say hey sports cars
are about to come back in a real way but
one of them was dads
in my age who were really in that prime
collecting year of that golden era which
also then became the junk wax era
started having children that were
interested in cards and and I thought
there was a wee loop in the same way
that I learned at Hasbro and Mattel when
they were clients of being our media
that toy franchises tend to leap every
25 or 30 years because the parent really
gets interested in their kids being a
part of their so anyway I keep telling
this story but I want to just remind
everybody if you're just jumping on I'm
doing full Q&A we're gonna start taking
questions very shortly if you have a
question about sports cards just text me
right now
we've got it pulled up here too one two
nine three one five seven three one put
in your question we're gonna call you
and you're gonna ask your question so
put in your question we're gonna call
you right here so we can banter back and
forth Pro Conner and different I go to
the national in Cleveland two years ago
kind of very stealth for a day and a
half take my little guy buy him a bunch
of cards watch learn I then spend a
couple months really really spending my
time on eBay and reading forums and blog
posts about what has happened met a
bunch of different prominent dealers ask
them questions about the Lost years for
me of like what happened during the
lower production years what are these
basketball inserts started following a
bunch of Instagram accounts started
getting really passionate about it
quietly started you know getting into it
a little bit louder at times to you know
fifteen or so months ago maybe even more
sixty months ago just started talking
about the fact that I thought gee honest
at that point I decided basketball was a
really good bet
I thought giannis was super underpriced
because I thought he was on the verge of
becoming the best basketball player in
the world
couldn't believe how inexpensive his
rookies were made some of that content
as first-time some of you saw me on that
sold some of the ones that I've
accumulated for 200 bucks that's bad now
since there's what 2600 maybe even more
I thought that was a good bet started
thinking other things were good bets put
out a blog post 10 months ago on things
that I saw that I thought were
underpriced Jordans sticker cuz I think
leader stickers were under priced
basketball in general vintage basketball
soccer wrestling big shout-out to King
Kong Bundy or the greats still has the
fastest win in WrestleMania when he
destroyed us Steve Jones in like 12
seconds or something that got really
excited about it got super hyped from
national last year where I met a ton of
the people in the industry got a table
there was super pumped about that
did a collaboration with tops tops maybe
$25,000 to curate a set that they sold
at the event that was cool that was fun
to be part of a baseball card was an
insert in series 2 super pumped about
that met a ton of people at the national
last year paid attention to the trends
and felt like a couple things that
emerged one sneaker collector kids
needed to address the fact that
inventory was getting harder to get has
over the last decade because you
couldn't really go to sneaker stores by
up and then flip that the stock X I POS
did Nike direct like that game was
changing and those entrepreneurs which
is another thing entrepreneurship as a
whole what I grew up with is one of the
reasons I think this is happening
sneaker kids needing an outlet to get
inventory and flip because that's what
they are is an outlet more collectors
growing because 40 year olds now have
some of them now have more income to buy
the card that they always wanted I think
there's a prop here for me this 84 tops
Don Mattingly rookie card was like the
biggest deal to me when I was a kid you
know being able to get it in a in a 10
we'll get into grading we'll get into
the grading companies we'll get into the
companies that own the IP of these cards
kept watching the space kept seeing
momentum build and you know three or
four months ago said like wow this is
about to get very serious there's just
more demand coming in supply on the
vintage stuff
is quite low supply on the modern stuff
in the super premium has been
manipulated to be low one of ten one of
ones you know autos and just general
production I do think the popularity of
sports cards is gonna lead the paninis
and tops to start producing Bowman
you know select down optic like bigger
quantity levels I don't know any details
but it surely I'm aware of that or I
believe where I've heard through the
grapevine that production numbers on
panini basketball this year obviously a
hell of a lot higher than they were in
2012 and so what does the debate become
between the volume of population output
between the Kawhi Leonard rookie and as
ion there's gonna be a big Delta there
so all the trends that you saw happen in
86 to 94 will happen again from the
panini top standpoint up or that they
should those companies are in the
business of selling product we need to
be thoughtful of how we supply and
demand that the grading company dynamic
even know PSA started in 1991 I faded
out in 94 and it still had not really
hit my radar I was a smaller dealer punk
kid in New Jersey so I wasn't going to
the national I'm sure you saw the early
indications of that now that is a
standard there is a human subjectiveness
and grading cards from SGC bgs and PSA
which i think would have three top
leaders and there's some other companies
which brand no different than south of
bees and Tiffany's and and Christie's
holds the most value which brand is the
brand of the moment I have a lot of
thoughts a lot the things to share I
myself I'm trying to navigate the sports
card world right now like I don't know
what's right for me to do like do I buy
things quietly and never share it and
just like live my life I want to talk
about it because I'm excited about it
and I also spend my life trying to tell
people you know things that I see to
share to make their worlds better and so
no different than me thinking that you
should do tick tock no different than
I'm telling everybody years ago to buy
Facebook stock at 20 or 30 dollars a
share I genuinely think sports cars are
gonna continue to go up quite a bit
gambling is a huge thread you know if
you look at the average 15 to 30 year
old male and female but like the culture
of sports fans they love to gamble daily
fantasy sports regular gambling the
demonization of gambling is going away
if you really look at what makes it fun
to open packs it is gambling you can
literally buy a $200 pack you can
literally pull a $10,000 card breaking
culture this dynamic of people you know
on YouTube
opening up packs and people buying slots
or them just entertaining has in the
same way that slime for little girls
work is happening for sports cards a lot
of people are watching that content
there's a there's a lot of dynamics in
play to why I think sports card 44 year
old is looking like I don't want to buy
[ __ ] art like I want to buy some
[ __ ] old [ __ ] art of some
Englishman or a [ __ ] scene of a hill
like my art is this my art is this like
I want to build a case in my home and
when my friends come over I don't want
to be like here's a Picasso [ __ ] Pablo
Picasso I want to show them like stack
of 150 hakeem olajuwon rookie cards
that's cooler for me that's more
interesting for me and so I think when
you look at the average 35 to 60 year
old business man and woman they're more
casual they care more about their stuff
and I think sports cards has the
potential very quickly to become the
kind of thing that people display in
their homes no different than a nice
painting and I think that's gonna happen
of comic books and I think you're gonna
see that quite a bit
I think Bieber posted a post maybe six
months ago where he showed a huge stack
of like his epic Pokemon collection that
he bought so I think that's a dynamic I
think there's a lot of dynamics I think
there's a lot of emerging things that
are dangerous I think a lot of people
are getting into it that are not
educated they may follow me and get
super excited and then just go buy stuff
without knowing what grading company is
good what what brands are good they're
just blindly buying I think there's you
know trimming you know there's people
that are altering cards and you got a
human grading this that creates a
vulnerability that became that becomes a
big deep thing that people are concerned
about I understand fraudulent plays and
coins and art and everything else as
well so there's a lot of stuff going on
that's my framework I'm super excited
about it I think there's some epic
long-term opportunities for me long-term
opportunities look like this you know
LeBron is everyone's Jordan of this
generation and like
I don't know how people are confused by
this it's [ __ ] LeBron and god forbid
he wins a title this year or anywhere in
the next 36 months he starts getting
into some really interesting
conversations not to mention I don't
know if you've been following LeBron
James as a human but so many of the good
things he does as a human is gonna keep
him culturally relevant he wants a play
into a son plays like if that works out
that's gonna be a cultural moment in six
years or whatever the kids age is that
right now and then there's this
underpriced vintage basketball I think
basketball is clearly the next iconic
sport in America and it's a global sport
in a lot of ways that's why I also like
soccer and so I'm very hot on the dr.
J's the Kareem abdul-jabbar's Lew
Alcindor rookie the Oscar Robbins and
then I'm think there's a nice little
stack of magic and bird rookies that I
have historically thought or underpriced
and then I so and then there's betting
there's short-term betting baseball's
coming around right now a lot of you've
seen on Twitter me getting excited about
baseball much like gambling sports cards
helps you enjoy sports more I could give
two shits unless Juan Soto was on my
fantasy team which he's not because in
our dynasty league who's got so no
cinema or somebody's gonna keep him so
he's not gonna be available to me which
means I would not care about him at all
now because I think he's one of the best
young players in baseball has but tech I
think he has the potential to be better
than a Cunha in a world right thing to
Cunha is all time as well like that's
gonna make it exciting for me to watch
like I think it really pumped about
Nationals baseball now because if Soto
hits four homers that market fluctuates
that's like fun that's what the Pete
Alonso theory was for me a couple weeks
ago people love the long ball let's
don't get it twisted five-tool athletes
are great for actual baseball if Pete
Alonzo it's 53 [ __ ] home runs again
this year with his popularity and the
way he rolls in New York that becomes a
supply and demand it's just supply and
demand there's the marketing side and
there's the collecting side for many
people in the Hobby collecting is their
passion and things going up in price is
not fun I respect the [ __ ] out of that
on the same token there's a lot of
people who flip it to me I don't get to
make a judgement on capitalism
you know like she'll be made out of that
with real estate should be mad at that
about America a lot of people I've
looked at though
the their their Twitter streams that
have been mad at me that say you should
only collect this should not be about
flipping but then when you look at their
Twitter stream they're pushing a lot of
capitalism and business first agenda so
they want to suppress the business
dynamic of these cards in their hobby
but they don't want to do it in other
places which i think is inherently
selfish cards have been flipped forever
and that will always stay whether I
disappear tomorrow or not and I enjoy it
the way I enjoy any business because I'm
an entrepreneur that happens like sports
that's who I am as a human so I think
there's a lot of opportunity I got more
cards on here I'm a big believer in
stickers
I think soccer culture is gonna bleed
into our culture and if you look at
soccer cards historically they're
stickers or the rookie card
so I think there's a lot of stickers
from panini which is a huge brand now in
90s and 80s in basketball so that's why
I have this just a lot of stuff I'm
looking at I'm looking at it daily
I think weird cards are interesting this
is an 86 JM s Barclay which was like a
hand cut out card
I think it's under priced because I
think it's super interesting and weird
and earlier than his 8687 Fleer rookie
card a different one I think a lot about
supply and demand
I do think over time population matters
a lot of people talking right now like
holy [ __ ] look how many Lucas and Zions
are on from a population standpoint I
keep saying look it's just supply and
demand so if there's 40,000 people that
want to own a Zion rookie then 10,000 is
not gonna be a problem
when there isn't then there is a problem
and I think a lot of people need to be
very careful you have some questions I
think I've said enough at this point I
want to be very interactive let's roll I
also want to say in 17 minutes I have to
step out and make a quick family call
I'll be right back can you call the
person yeah I want to interact with the
people so we can do some follow-up so
that's all going on I'm super excited
about it there's a lot of people that I
think we're gonna get a lot of enjoyment
you know Jim's here he wrote a great
LinkedIn post he works on my team II
ironically used to work at Beckett when
I hired we'd even talk once about that
when we hired or maybe we met I think
you might have mentioned it for a second
but that's super cool they get into the
happiness factor that I thought you
wrote about better than anybody on your
Linkedin happiness financial opportunity
not being bothered by people or
collectors and
there's a lot of themes every Daniel
Andrew Daniel Oh Daniel hey it's Gary
Vaynerchuk how are you I'm good how are
you I'm quite well what can I answer for
you hey so I had a question about these
uh
sports cars cuz I'm sure you know well
obviously the market is blowing up
lately and I've seen some theories
online saying that maybe it's cause for
this is a lot of money that investors
like you maybe your companies are
putting in the market so I want to get
your thoughts on potentially is the
market overinflating right now and an
impending crash and then knocked off our
future so I think there's a lot to that
Daniel I'm sorry is that it Daniel I
think there's a couple things yeah
number one
anytime there's more demand it's less
about money being pumped in its demand
so when Dumbo was a piece of [ __ ] in
Brooklyn and and and Williamsburg were
pieces of [ __ ] 15 years ago and more
people started buying up that inherently
changes the dynamic it's no different
than when I was telling people to buy
Facebook stock at 40 when when their
business results were better and more
people wanted it it's just supply and
demand of how many shares are are versus
how many people want it
I think couple things that matter number
one let there be no confusion long
before two years ago when I started
getting interesting and then a year and
a half when I got louder and maybe 30 a
hundred days ago when I got much louder
there was already the reason it even hit
my radar to pay attention was things
were already happening without me there
was already demand starting to bubble up
that's what I was watching for i watch
for slime with you know teenage girls
for tick-tock I'm a culture I'm a
consumer behavior anthropologist that's
what I do for a living that's why I
vaynermedia is one of the biggest
agencies in the world we're good at
strategy and we're good at making videos
and pictures for that strategy so a
couple things the answers absolutely and
do I think that there's a vulnerability
to that with prices coming down of
course the question becomes that's only
predicated if demand goes away the
question becomes is less about me
putting money in or other people putting
money in the question becomes how many
six to twenty year olds are about to get
interesting in this and how long will it
sustain I think one of the biggest
vulnerabilities to the sports card
market is everything's expensive now
pack of basic cards just three bucks
that keeps a lot of kids out of it I
think one of the best things that panini
and tops can do is come out with a
99-cent product I think it's important
to keep a lot of youth into collecting
and flipping and so I'll be honest with
you my intuition is we haven't seen
anything yet
because I'm getting bombarded and I'm
watching other things that people that
have nothing to do with me and have
never heard of me somebody made a post
yesterday on social like look I own a
card store in Canada not a single
[ __ ] person that's walked in my
sword' knows who the [ __ ] Gary
Vaynerchuk is and basketball cards are
flying off the shelf like to me
everyone's like he's inflating I'm like
I haven't said a single thing about Zion
I owned how many Zions do I am ducek
zero so that I own zero Zions now I'm
not pumped about that but to me it was
like injury risk I think if Diane gets
hurt before the end of the year like the
the floor up collapses and I also think
that panini made a lot more product and
I think once people get to those numbers
now Zion could be a forever player on
the level of LeBron and Jordan and then
that plays out but for me you can't
invest in everybody like Torres on the
Yankees excites the [ __ ] I mean I just
can't bet on all nine guys that are
really exciting for me in baseball and I
don't think it's even fun to bet on
everybody cuz for me a lot of this is
like are you right or wrong I feel great
about how right I was about giannis I
still feel great about the Aaron Fox
just cuz he was injured and the team
hasn't clicked I don't think that
changes my belief in who he is over the
next decade so it's fun to be and by the
way I'm excited to be wrong let me give
you some my highlights when I was a kid
I over invested in Todd Van Poppel did
not work out I thought he's gonna be
sayang I invested and this was both my
heart an ungodly amount of percentage of
money I had I'm Blair Thomas score
rookie cards did not work out like I
have nothing boat Kimball I thought was
gonna be the greatest basketball player
of all time on the flip side I was
incredibly wrong about Patrick mahomes
that was more on just me and my friends
talking about if I thought he was gonna
be good less a sports card so I think
it's like any market in the world
brother like it's just supply and demand
and I think we're not in I think we're
in the second quarter of demand with
sports cards which means there's more
room
to grow and I think if you spend 80% of
your energy and time on the classics
Jordan Brady - guys I don't love so much
but like clearly goats in their industry
LeBron you know like to me you know even
wrestling like the rock or like like I
think if you stay conservative on
classics or all-time players and then
you have a little fun on prospects do
you think Jaron Jackson's gonna be good
or not do you think John Collins in
Atlanta is gonna be good or not you know
that you think Sancho is gonna be good
or not
boom bop a like those are fun little
bets I think if you're the kind of
person that's coming into this and
buying a ton of right now Soto and a
Cunha and betting on they're gonna be
trout and you know like you need to be
very careful because if they're not the
demand is gonna get soft and you can get
caught I mean look at Russell Westbrook
in the heat of all of this and the heat
of basketball his cards are down because
for a lot of us we don't think he's
gonna reach that next plateau and a lot
of the money was in it and so I think
you have to be careful about that does
that make sense yeah good luck thank you
thank you
one of things I like about wrestling so
I actually think comic books has you can
get the next call has a lot more upside
than cards in a lot of ways just that I
love cards and I like sports betting and
I think that's bleeding into this and I
like sneakers but like Ironman doesn't
get hurt right and neither does King
Kong Bundy or
the rock so I think West hello who's
this Andrew what's good you chopped the
rap good to talk to you - what's your
question brother at all so my big
question is I came from the old world of
the 96 s where I was collecting Iverson
Kobe or even clutters coming back to it
obviously because what's through there
bear grylls have older kids now by
dollar seven on for getting back into it
just like any whatever so my big thing
is last year I started I'm not looking
for Lucas but I was pulling my question
to evenings do you think it's a better
strategy as a collective
act in two five boxes baby over to flip
to buy like a 19th acres or just enjoy
the sport of just opening their package
very well I think the answer is you have
to be very self aware and focus on you
not what I say not what others say this
is a single game of what brings you
happiness my friend old Lou right who's
little loose dad he loves opening wax
now if he lands a one of one of an
iconic card he could make that if he
does he pulled the one of one wander
Franco it would have made his whole
venture ry+ it's unlikely that most
people pull such a big pull that it
makes it ROI positive if you make bets
on players there is a more financial
potential of return especially through
good at it the problem is it might not
be as fun for you Alex right like like
opening packs is fun as [ __ ] like it's
gambling it's gambling so different
things like a nice diamond card you get
tons of different people different
companies that are not terrible right
right now and then and then Zion gets
hurt he was already missed a big chunk
of the beginning of the season and if
Zion gets hurt the market falls apart
right right so like Rick or he's Yonex
and Luka and keeps going through the
roof and it seems cheap right now what
what what you know one thing I've
noticed of people who've raised me on
Twitter they're like this guy comes in
and thinks he's an expert I don't think
that at all I don't think I'm an expert
at all first of all I'm excited to do
this Q&A and answer I don't know there's
a big gap in my game I just don't know I
do know certain things
I know macro trends of human behavior
pretty well which is why I've built a
big career and I know that I also follow
sports and and I also have the luxury of
being a place in my life where I
probably know who the human being is a
little bit better than most people
because I own a sports agency I run in
circles that allows me to get to know
some of these people and guess what
you're one of your biggest
vulnerabilities is you think the kid
jump out the building but you actually
don't know that he's a piece of trash
and he's gonna be out of league in three
years because of his human behavior so
there's a lot that goes into this
there's also Derrick Rose if I was
getting involved right now I'd be and it
was right before Derrick Rose got hurt
and he's an MVP the youngest of the
league and well on his way and a big
market and swaggy as [ __ ] I'm important
real money into Derrick Rose and then he
goes on to becoming so injured it
doesn't work out there's Andrew Luck my
favorite thing is to figure out which
quarterback is gonna put another ring on
to explode Andrew Luck would have been
at the top of that list and he just
[ __ ] retires so there's an enormous
amount of risk in this game which is why
putting it into a place of what brings
you the most happiness I'm not going to
open a lot of packs I'm gonna do it at
the National when I'm excited I'm gonna
do it with my buddies once in a while
like what the NFL Draft me when it were
in the second day we like to open packs
because that's a little slow sometimes
when we got the Vayner stuff but for me
it's much more I'm spending 80 percent
of my money on LeBron on Oscar Robinson
61 Fleer from SGC cuz I think SGC is
underpriced over time because for me why
this prism have to be the leader why
can't it be optic like like which is I
bring in art because I think it's it's
why I tried to buy Lukas last night on
optic and then what am I supposed to do
like I'm trying to figure out different
Cadence's do i buy up stuff but then
everybody whispers I tried something
different yesterday I said here's my
price on Lucca
but then it went from 350 530 I don't
know like how to play this cuz there's a
lot of attention on me right now and I
don't know if what the right thing to do
is what I'm gonna do is transparency
like I'm thinking about like updating
how many I like like the Zion thing from
the last kid like so somebody hit me up
today's like you're hoarding Zions I'm
like I own zero Zions like so you know
and by the way I'm dick [ __ ] compared to
who's coming over the next two years it
is my belief that the Dwyane Wade's the
offsets the babies the Diddy I think a
lot of people gonna start collecting I'm
gonna be minor leagues in 24 months yeah
you think I'm moving the market wait to
[ __ ] Diddy puts a post with libera
in his Instagram like people are
confused of where we are right now I
don't think I'm moving it as much people
think there's a hundred things moving
that have nothing to do with me you have
to have fun with your kids you should
provide your money manager I would tell
you to offset that with 50 percent of
investment on things that you think are
ironclad like if you believe and by the
way I'm buying everything for the next
cycle when I buy LeBron or Magic Johnson
or old basketball or other things I'm
buying for the next cycle I'm actually
already thinking about the next dip in
four years
or three or two or seven and then 21
years from now because LeBron and Kobe
aren't going anywhere
and that's why basketball and soccer
really fascinate me because I'm
projecting them to be more popular in 20
years I actually I love it
Alex keep going just enjoy it and try to
make sure you don't get overexposed
financially let's get one more in a four
minutes before my call
when we got new Jonathan John John it's
Gary Vaynerchuk how are you do it really
well how you do it um well what question
can I answer yeah so I am curious about
soccer cars I think they're really
undervalued me too
I've taken up killing a poppy bunny too
if there's just no true rookies like I
mean I've taken up a buncha Kilian
objects from this period your [ __ ] you
know pop chrome prism optic what do you
figure on that the biggest thing I'm
thinking about is that the hobbies gonna
evolve like when I left cards Shaq's
rookie was stadium club not not the bean
team it was the upper deck right like
yeah like right now one of the things
I'm thinking a lot about is tops chrome
is basketballs rookie card way back but
could it be upper deck like I'm thinking
about how the answer is the hobby
decides what the current true rookie is
and over a thirty-year pin window it
actually changes which is why I'm
starting to really think about
alternatives for example I think tops
regular basketball cards rookies are
potentially underpriced that's why let
me pull it up it's why I've started
buying a little bit of like the regular
base tops not just the chrome like to
answer your question is it the sticker
is it the pen is it panini as a tops
chrome the market doesn't like for
example ice personally for who knows why
I'm a human being like the tops update
in series to baseball as the rookie card
more than the chrome but in five years
because chrome is so cool and if you
look at tops chrome and panini and an
optic they're more Cromie out one could
argue that everybody getting excited
back up back down a cunha top series to
later one could argue that the tops
Chrome's are grossly underpriced because
in seven years they become the true
rookie that goes above my pay grade and
everybody else that's the that's the
world deciding what the true rookie is
in baseball back in the day it was the
Don Russ Mattingly rookie card not the
tops like this [ __ ] evolves and I'd be
very scared to tell you which one by the
way one of the reasons
I really like the JMS Berkeley one of
the reasons I like the 1972 IC set one
of the reasons I like some of these we
are there's an Elvin Hayes
rookie card I have there's a
jack-in-the-box 1968 Elvin Hayes that I
like because it's older than his rookie
and I'm like why can't that be the
rookie that's a card before it's not an
official set like tops but maybe maybe
for example the converse sets the IC
sets the Nike Jordan 85 like if you
think about the masses getting in why
isn't them Nike Jordan 85 cooler than
the 86 leader cuz Nikes are a lot cooler
than [ __ ] FLIR I think there's a lot
of things that people haven't [ __ ]
figured out yet yeah I got a convert and
I'm looking at the visual appeal so for
media boffin I just got a bunch of prism
blue because it's blue on you know who
love the Jersey and you know that's
that's how I'm making those choices how
I love it I love it brothers thank you
so much yeah thank you okay all right
here's what I'd like to do I'm about to
go and do this quick call Jim I'd like
you to sit in here and tell your story
and then I want if I'm not back there's
only 5 minutes tell your story about
what you wrote in LinkedIn it throw
super interesting I know I do you're
doing this so I think it's really cool
because I think for a lot of people
enjoyment and happiness I don't get
enjoyment and buying Netflix stock and
it going through the roof just cuz I
knew Netflix was a good buy I get a hell
of a lot more enjoyment in buying sports
cards like from an investment safer you
talked a lot about enjoyment and
happiness and your LinkedIn post I like
that and then I think for anybody else
like if I should be back by time he's
done but John like Dean like some of you
old man Lou look if you want to get in
here like you know whatever whatever
Mike playa if you want to sit here and
talk about how I yelled at you two years
ago to get in and you didn't you didn't
you didn't you did it and like what the
how do you think about that like just
fill up the space here for five minutes
I'll be right right back it's okay it's
okay
oh you need the mics from me got it okay
okay both of them
Jim you go first this is certainly
unplanned oh good golly so yeah I think
the story that that Gary's referring to
is I wrote a blog post on LinkedIn last
week and the main point was that Gear's
been talking about sports cards for like
he said a year and a half couple years
and I really hadn't bought in because as
he said I used to be the editor of
Beckett baseball back in the 90s and so
I was there when it crashed and I saw a
lot of hard-working people lose their
money and we're really hurt and I wasn't
ready to get back into it and then as I
continue to hear Gary talk about it it
just started to make more sense to me
that now was an opportunity because of
that because we had seen the 90s and we
had seen what overproduction looks like
and so now there was probably a better
opportunity to invest in a smarter way
so what I did was being an older guy I
talked to my wife and I said hey I'd
like to buy some cards over the next
five six months I'm probably gonna spend
about a thousand dollars not a ton but
thousand dollars is not cheap there's
not nothing either in my house so over
that six months I just started buying
Lou help me help me along said hey you
know a lot of people get invested in
Bowman paper rookies so I started
looking at like ten eleven twelve
different rookies in the twenty nine
twenty nineteen Bowman set they said
look I'm gonna I'm gonna invest in fifty
hundred twenty two hundred of these
rookies and sit on them for a year and
see how they do
now so I started doing that and then
something happened because the NBA
all-star game came around and I'm
sitting there watching the NBA all-star
game with with my son will and we open
up the draftkings app and I'm like tell
you what let's put 10 bucks on this game
it doesn't matter let's put 10 bucks on
it
and we broke it up into like a bunch of
little two-dollar prop bets throughout
the game and it was it was really fun we
spent three hours laughing joking
yelling screaming about these dumb $2
little two dollar prop bets on the NBA
all-star game and had an absolute blast
and so what what it triggered to me or
what it convinced me was what Gary said
was that I'd kind of demonized gambling
it's like Oh gambling is bad no one
should gamble it's terrible it's like
yeah it's got some downsides you need to
be really careful with it but there was
some opportunity to use it in a very
positive way to have some fun and some
enjoyment without going overboard and
that's where I started to think about
cards that way too that you could you
could invest in cards without going
overboard and add a lot of enjoyment
with the people you share it with like
your your kids and you could do it in a
way that you could decide your level of
risk you could decide how how how far
you want to be in it and at the end I
feel like yeah there's a thousand
dollars I've got in baseball cards but
those may or may not pay off over over
the next year or two but for sure I've
had a ton of fun buying those cars
researching those cards doing the
analytics behind it Gary I know you're
like always talking about researching
like I'm not kidding you the research is
the fun part
going through eBay and looking at what's
available what it costs is the fun part
and so whether that thousand dollars
pays off or not I feel like I'm I've won
either way so that's how I choose to get
back into it and it's a pretty limited
fashion
[Applause]
all right let's get the next question
you don't have the phone okay give me
the question because I'm more educated
on it I'm a little bit more educated on
base cards I understand that the one of
ones like I understand that if I poured
that same level of money into giannis or
Luka I probably could have made a bigger
financial return I just still don't know
where I sit so one of my biggest
theories is that this whole industry is
about to get a lot bigger and so for me
there's not that many people that can
afford a $15,000 pair of off-white Nike
moma on stock X but there's a lot of
people that can afford a $300,000 pair
and so for me one of the things I'm
thinking about is if the masses come how
many people gonna be able to afford a
$4,000
giannis versus a lower-end one it's one
of the reasons I'm looking at really
other thing as you know I'm looking at
the hoops I'm looking at hoops was
thinking think about hoops oh you're
gone like through some of these
lower-cost ones are they actually going
to be the market because you're getting
an influx of people and I just think
that it's gonna be I think I think
industry needs to understand that the
level of amount of people that are
getting in right now are different
they're not hardcourt hobbyists they're
the people that are just like either
like Jim and Alex and I getting back
into it there's a whole crew of like
sneaker kids and just like kids that
like sports and gambling that are coming
in we're just gonna have a new dynamic
and I think there'll be some pros and
cons from that for me bass has been a
place that I one of things I tell
everybody please pay attention to this a
lot of you spend 30 to 40 to 50 hours of
searching eBay completed read articles
read Twitter there's so many people that
interact with me on Twitter that are
both saying I'm good and saying I'm bad
that have a lot of good things to say
that are wildly you know wildly ajik
one thing that I always tell my brands
is like look he can't look at yesterday
to know what tomorrow is gonna bring
so a lot of people have been in the
business for last 20 years or been
collecting for last twenty years or
applying old dynamics so they're like
all these population numbers are
amazingly high 9,000 PSA tens the
problem is if there's 40,000 people like
I said earlier that want it that's gonna
throw off supply didn't wonder used to
only be a thousand trout's but only 400
people wanted it that's that if there's
10,000 trout's but 50,000 that want it
like I don't think people are gonna be
able to calibrate the demand this is
what always happens is why people
thought Facebook was a was overpriced as
a stock and I thought it was under
priced this is why real estate always
happens they're like ah we missed it
like a lot of you right now think you
missed it like [ __ ] this [ __ ] Lucca
went from 35 to 600 meanwhile but what
if it's actually two thousand or two
every or please understand what if it's
two thousand and then Luca has a Paul
George like oh I thought about this the
other day Paul George was on his way you
want to talk about a guy I would have
poured real money into it was the Paul
George a month before his horrific
injury I would have lost now for me it's
less loss because I'm playing long like
the only gambling I'm really doing coz
the National is every July I'm gambling
with young baseball because young
baseball is fun for me like I can get
more into baseball I'm trying to be
better at fantasy because the last
couple years I've been like too busy so
it's gonna force me to be better a fan
this is a lot of personal expect Alex
back to Jim why am i investing in in
young baseball
it makes me pay attention to the fantasy
more and I'm in a 30 year now league
with these guys
and I want to get better cuz last couple
years I've fallen off because I'm busy a
[ __ ] number two the National is like now
becoming like my Disney World trip
I can't wait to Atlantic City in July
and like going to that national what's
happening then baseball hardcore
baseball is having there so if Alonso's
got [ __ ] 32 homers buy time have lat
late July that's gonna matter at the
show you know and so like that's why
baseball is interesting to me it's
really not in this scheme of like a 30
year window the way I'm investing
because you know you could be a great
player and not really matter thirty
years later I think dr. J and Kareem are
in a better place than P
or Roberto Clemente long term got a pack
of wrestling cards here I'm really like
wrestling I do like wrestling cards I've
bought a lot thirty Dan
Oh mr. Fuji was the [ __ ] best hello
Dan it's Gary Vaynerchuk let's go I
pulled a Randy the Macho Man Savage
Braille I'm super [ __ ] Punk
let's go Don the rock good go ahead my
man yeah I'm gonna say so with all the
rising cost and we're not cops but
writing writing sales sports cards
everything pretty much go up day after
day now damn especially in basketball
baseball do you think that we're running
any sort of risk of a bubble burst or do
you think word of course in a new
Explorer I please go ahead I'm sorry I
was gonna say it was kind of reach out
for that too in my opinion I think that
this news is gonna write that certain
people they were trying to jump into
collecting so I think that's going to
open up a world of the TSA nines and
there I even say like bgs 8.5 becoming
sellable grade or I've 104 was it Luke I
bought 104 Luca hoops PSA tens because
I'm like or the secondary sets become
more interesting right so to your point
right is it gonna be a PS 9 prism world
or is it gonna be a world where some of
the second and third-tier price stuff
goes up on their PSA tens I don't know
but I think you're right I think that
you know just like art I don't know if
you guys heard but there's 100 million
dollar art paintings and then there's
art you can buy for 90 bucks on iconic
you know what I mean like there's a
range and so to your point what I don't
know and I haven't really figured out
yet for me for my investment strategy is
that PSA now is a PSA 9 and you know I
think beat you know listen I'll be
honest with you just like the rookie
changes that matters the number one
thing I'm trying to
you're out is in 14 years if PSA is not
the leading brand and SGC or bgs is
could you imagine it for you and I want
to do a time machine and 14 years from
now a BG s 9.5 carried more weight than
a PSA 10 just think about the price
difference today
like what like we're relying on brands I
mean I'll be very frank with you one of
the things that's really got my
attention is I just like the way in SGC
case with its black looks compared to
its PSA counter power and I've also had
found from what I've submitted that SVC
has been more difficult on their grading
makes me wonder if FG CC has some upside
it could also go out of business
tomorrow because it's a small company
like oh so I think you're I think what
everyone's about to figure out is do PSA
9 in modern is that the ARB or is it
tops regular is it you know I put a
bunch of bazooka about seven for how
many bazooka I want to be really
transferable I bought 11 bazooka LeBron
rookie cards because I'm like well if
the [ __ ] chrome is gonna be 20,000
and people start coming in droves and
they want a LeBron they're gonna have to
look at other stuff I mean I think the
tops regular rookie cards are a [ __ ]
arbitrage I'm buying a ton of Durant
tops regular I'm buying curry tops
regular I'm buying LeBron tops regular I
think the tops regulars a very
interesting basketball card from that
one little era when they had it and to
your point if these prime mean if a
[ __ ] Lucas $2,000 next year in a PSA
10 prism that is so enough that's I mean
that's game over how the [ __ ] are you
can afford that by the way by the way
let me throw something I never thought
about which is why I like doing QA what
if raw comes back heavy because of it
alright
it might look again back to some of the
heat I'm taking from the establishment I
don't think I'm right I think I'm just
communicating alternatives that may
happen if I'm right about something I do
think I'm right about which is a drove
of interest is coming I mean I'm getting
DMS from card store owners ones that
make fun of me but then hit me up
quietly on the back end people
local shows seeing levels of interests
that we've never seen before thoughts
yeah I mean I really especially on the I
mean you know not in my opinion as we
see stuff like the LeBron curl or the
pollutant prisms but I mean the Luther
prisms are going up like crazy right now
so I think we are going to see a lot of
opportunity with the optic which is
starting to get kind of crazy but also
now I think by the way by the way I
apologize for interrupting optic the
population on PSA ten optic is like a
thousand something and the panini is
like and the prism excuse me is like
eight thousand on the luca eleven
thousand right so like right you know
like and it looks like the optics are
tough to grade you know that's the other
thing here look there's a lot of things
that haven't been figured out I think
2012 prism is gonna go through the roof
once people realize production numbers
mmm-hmm like it's LeBrons first he put
like I there's just a lot of [ __ ] I'm
trying to figure out there's a lot and a
lot it's a very exciting and not
exciting time in sports cards depending
on where you sit if you like the way it
always was
you're probably frustrated if you're
excited about new dynamics happening
it's an incredible time I like what's
happening with Alex who called earlier
and Jim I think this thing brings a lot
of happiness
I think people buy and sell and collect
a lot of things on earth I think sports
cars are special because yes comic books
are safer and Iron Man doesn't get hurt
but you have to wait three years for
something to happen to a comic book a
new movie comes out sports cards if Juan
Soto hits two homers opening day I'm
gonna be losing my [ __ ] mind
don't let Luca don't let Luca single
handily put his team on his back and
create an upset in the first round the
NBA playoffs you think Luke is expensive
now do not let him drop 52 in a game
seven and then and they beat whoever
that their lower seed of because they're
like don't let that happen do not let
that happen
do not let Luca drop 52 in Game seven
against a better team and knock them out
because this hobby is gonna lose their
[ __ ] mind
on the flip side put Paul George
no I'm sorry I'm just a getting excited
because I think people think people
think they're right or or I think I'm
right or other people there is no right
first of all sports
fucking-a Calhoun who I think's could
have a breakout here got hit in the face
with a fastball yesterday fractured his
[ __ ] face you know
everybody went crazy on a Cunha what if
a Cunha tears his labrum on opening day
sports that's why I really like
basketball cuz I think basketball
players are the closest thing to
superheroes that's my favorite one that
Lou makes fun of me of buying all the
time is this hard right let's find it
where is it earnest I love this card
George Gervin 74 times Iceman yes the
Iceman all I need is one Netflix
documentary on this guy and this card
goes from 180 to 800 right so like
everyone's playing different angles I
don't know make sense okay good luck
brother
enjoy all right oh yeah let's keep it
going we're Jordans excite me I think
this is one of the most interesting cut
like this is a look up big this this is
you're like hanging your leg off I mean
I hate this [ __ ] but Brian I think
that's super underpriced there's just
not that many of them in her lake this
card then there's the baiting I'm like
I'm looking at this somebody somehow can
eight not a seven got a resubmit let's
go to next one well we go next one
Akeem I'm buying because I think Africa
is gonna be a Content on the global map
in 30 years I'm buying this card for 30
years from now not to mention he's one
of the 15 best players of all time and
it's grossly underpriced high I think
meanwhile like I love hockey but I can't
get that excited couple in there right
nope Jean what is that
Steinmetz I'm sorry I apologize how are
you
I'm good bro good bro what you like
chocolate you're gonna call me you doing
I did I thought you know they know it
put three times with it this time and
what do you do don't know what let's do
it my question is uh yeah sky mints yeah
what's your question brother so uh for
someone who has like a hundred dollars
you know not too much money and come out
to work I don't watch like that I like
playing sports I want to watch it yep
so how how do I kind of how would I
trying to make money and I don't invest
the time that we know the players know
what's going on [ __ ]
yeah I mean look just cuz I think
there's an opportunity here I think
there's an opportunity a lot of places I
think with the coronavirus there's a ton
of opportunity right now in the stock
market that's toxic decline I think
there's a ton of opportunity and
opportunity zones in New Jersey like
Paterson and Newark I do there's
opportunities everywhere
I think there's opportunity by the way
maybe do you like Pokemon well bro
that's your answer pokemon cards are
outpacing sports cards get all in on
pokemon buy your first pokemon for 60
bucks that for 25 hours of homework
watch it go up from from to a hundred
thirty then flip it take that hundred
thirty buy the next one and two years
later you got something brewing bro I
would happily spend twenty to forty
hours studying pokémon completed items
on ebay read articles on that you search
on Google find some people on Twitter
that know get on a phone call learn go
to a show learn learn learn and then
decide oh this weird character I think
is underrated because I think it's just
really cool a lot of people in the
Pokemon community care about it and I
bet you it's gonna go up in price yeah
that's the answer brother this is self
awareness game like I like but it also
is what are you trying to do like I know
football cold but I think football has
too many and
and skill players defensive players
forget it their cards never go up and
even receivers and running backs are
thicker underpriced and not really
getting there so it becomes a
quarterback game only and so like to me
I know baseball because of my fantasy
league and I know basketball because
it's just by far the one that I most
believe in and so that's where I'm
playing but like I'm gonna bet with my
heart I'm gonna spend a good five
percent of my money and energy on Sam
darn old because I believe and I'm
playing betting with my heart so like I
think you need to do around your
interest and it sounds like pokemons a
lot better than sports and that's what's
going to matter number two number number
two is the most important part work is
required to be right about anything like
work is required but if not fun be out
like I'm petrified that people invest in
sports cards and don't know anything
about it don't enjoy it I'd rather than
be like gym and like get deep enjoyment
on buying Boman paper of prospects for
two years when I could get some joy
manaan it even though that might not be
the best ROI like I get enjoyment out of
is it Mookie Betts is it Bellinger is it
Rand owned is it Trevor story is it re
Ando like is what's the Colorado effect
what's not like I love these are nerdy
things I think about like Gavin Luck's
on a stack team versus what's the impact
of the Astros cheating scandal is yordan
gonna be good as Bregman gonna be good
it's I'll to me gonna be good or nay not
gonna be good because guess what if
you're didn't go Zinn hits 12 homers in
the first two weeks and everyone's like
okay well it's not that then that then
it's gonna explode and pass [ __ ] two
T's and [ __ ] Vlad and everybody else
there's nobody's talking about your
didn't baseball right now because it's
all hovered over the Astros thing but he
the [ __ ] trillion homers in the
minors last year I drafted him in our
fantasy league I know they weren't doing
that [ __ ] to minors I don't think even
though Lou's favorite teams got some
real allegations against it I know that
gets you personally upset
alright brother thanks for call let's
get the next one yeah I just think
there's a ton of arbitrage then there's
young guys Joe Adel like you people
think he's gonna be the best this rock
rookie I'm super excited
these are the things were thinking about
like the Bellinger thing to me is like
the Dodgers could be stacked Dodgers
could be stupid good this year and it's
LA and they love the [ __ ] you're calm
pitching already yeah do they have the
pitching but like their hitters are
gonna [ __ ] hit and it's momentum
one of the things I'm seeing the most of
this is momentum right now like people
this like Wayne above what I'm talking
about on Twitter there's a lot going on
with sports cards that I think people
need to recognize and I think it's I
think it's just beginning I think the
sneaker kids and the gambling kids are
gonna drive the [ __ ] out of this market
sneaker kids gambling kids dads that are
on the way but that's a lot of demand
that didn't exist 24 months ago hello
Dustin yeah that's Gary Vee how are you
hey how you doing I'm well I'm enjoying
this live stream
what can I answer get but it been really
good yeah Mike I apologize I'm gonna do
some rapid fire at some point I'm gonna
do that on Twitter so ask your questions
if you're watching on any stream go to
Twitter ask your questions I'm gonna
blue at some point do a lot rapid-fire
and take them Twitter but go ahead how
are you yeah no I'm doing good my my
question was as you kind of get back
into collecting cars if it's something
that you know like I'm a big baseball
guy so it is it better to kind of focus
up just on baseball by itself or is it
better to get kind of universal
knowledge and all the sports that are
out there it's back to self awareness so
for example do you have in you as a
human are you excited about the notion
to care about football hockey basketball
more like does that excite you do you
ever like a best friend who's a huge
basketball fan but you could never get
into it because one of the rationales is
one of the ways to really get into the
sport is to start collecting it because
basketball you think is the most
interesting thing to invest in and then
all of a sudden you care about who deer
and fox or jaren Jackson or John Kyle
like you you can sucker your way into
caring a lot more about basketball and
the reason you did it was macro you
thought it was the best investment and
your best friend Brandon is a huge
basketball fan and you wanted to have
more interest and oh by the way
basketball is a good offset the baseball
now you're covering 365 days a year and
like carrying around sports do you see
what I mean
yeah say it for me it says I'm from st.
Louis so obviously baseball town and
don't have a basketball team and
football team left so it's always been
kind of a you know baseball focus but no
it's definitely it's always interests me
with other sports but baseball kind of
has been worth that what look with
baseball there's demand coming in so top
15 players which I rattled off earlier
the debate of like how under price are
not under priced are they number two
you know in your farm system has been
stacked for years so you're probably
proud of this you know the youngsters
with bowman and their first hops is a
lot of it's a very fun game like you
know you know and then more importantly
not betting with your heart right not
getting caught on Dylan Carson or things
like you know not getting caught with
your heart the way I am with darn 'old
like being smart like not not buying
Nico because he's a cub because you hate
them like you know like or Herrera
because he's a Brewer because you hate
him like you have to be unemotional when
you're dealing with your monies ya know
that completely makes sense and I guess
that you've the kind of the fire of the
market has been really intriguing the
last few weeks and getting back into the
Hobby so this is all good stuff to learn
and work down so do me do me a favor get
very educated do you understand the
grading companies do you understand the
different companies that make cards do
you understand before you start betting
and then more importantly why are you
doing it you want it to be a hobby to
enjoy the games more do you want to make
a flip do you want to teach your kid
entrepreneurship do you want to have a
hobby that is profitable most hobbies
cost money like if you love skiing or if
you love you know hunt you like hunting
or if you like most things cost money
this is a hobby that you could break
even or even make money that's kind of
intriguing and a lot of people and a lot
of people are gambling to make sports
more fun which is very very very low
reward no matter how much people tell
you they're winning they're losing
gambling sucks it's an entertainment but
you're paying for it
whereas this can make sports a lot more
fun and the downside is much lower than
the upside yeah well you said you never
know someone get hurt when I get injured
and then you move on from there and you
and you know what could be fun you know
like it could be fun too like if you
know listen an average baseball game on
July 9th not necessarily the thing
that's gonna get your juices going
but when you are all in on a Cunha and
now the Braves are coming to town you're
gonna watch those three games a little
bit harder right yeah no that completely
makes sense Gary I definitely appreciate
all they're happy to do brother take
care
what's Lodge stern was that what's good
Instagram let me do this real quick
I don't know I'm gonna bring somebody on
real quick okay I'm sorry I'm for one
second go live with
nope see there's one if you wanted alive
with me real quick I'm about to bring
you in bad Vigo
Zion is gonna blow out his knees within
two years that would be bad though make
me super sad yo what's good I just want
to say what's up you're selling that
course the number the number one mistake
that people make in social media
marketing is there is their ads are just
sales not amplifying quality concept
before you get them into the funnel but
you have to make sure that the free
training is actually free training not
you subconsciously using that as a
funnel to make them pay and I'm
mentioning right to your [ __ ] face
right now it's very important bro
everyone's like I want to be like you
Garrity I'm like don't create funnels to
charge people just work on legacy then
it will come to you it's very [ __ ]
important when you're making a course
it's impossible to not try to sell the
course I don't want to talk about sports
cards because I want to flip these cards
and make less money in the flip than I
make in one [ __ ] speech I want
everybody's [ __ ] watching to make
money and be happier you need to not
worry about you making sales and fly
fishing you got to educate the masses at
scale for free about how epic
fly-fishing is and then it will come to
you more more MORE
you're welcome brother thank you
I admire you back keep going I admire
anybody who's going for it alright let's
keep it going this is fun Alex you're
getting questions on Twitter oh sorry I
can't get to the phone right now but
leave you boys I'll get back to you as
possible
Thank You Lou is right I'm devastated I
wanted to leave an angry angry voicemail
who's a while loop pulls up long form
questions Raghav once you go on Twitter
and just rattle off questions during
this Deadwood air time so we can just
get as many answers as possible because
we're not getting to the volume that I
want in these calls my my most prized
card is sitting somewhere here it's a
it's a 1990 Frank Thomas leaf rookie
because that was like the prized
everybody loved the griffey upper deck
rookie but for me I was in my prime when
ninety leaf Thomas which came a year
later there was just something about
that leaf said took the whole upper deck
thing up a notch had like I just also
liked Frank Thomas more I also bet on
Frank Thomas a 90 score the pick the one
with his big face on it I bought tons of
those before he hit the major leagues
and was like write about him so I felt a
bigger association to the big hurt than
I did Griffey so ninety Frank Thomas is
an emotional card for me you got some
stuff I'll get into Robin and we'll just
do a bunch and that's how we go Rob its
Gary Vaynerchuk life is good Rob I
appreciate me what's your question it
I need those trends you know backaches
was you know hype like crazy for years
you know dropped off the face of the
earth for a little while and I was
backing I mean it seems like it's [ __ ]
on another it is but I there's no way
that yeah I don't know I have no idea
when it ends number two I think it will
drop off the face of the earth it's
friends yeah it's like I'm here for guys
then short hair it's like jeans jeans
that are tight than genes that are baggy
people have to understand this is trends
things go up things go down it's why I
want people to invest in LeBron and
invest in Jordan and investing Brady and
invest in things that are like evergreen
because you're gonna get killed if you
decide to bet entree young trade doesn't
end up being an all-time top 25 player
and then the market collapses you're
gonna be [ __ ] finished now in the
meanwhile you can make a fortune on tray
if the market is super hot for six years
or if tray becomes Steph Curry in
perpetuity this is why I keep telling
people be smart like as fun as it is to
like bet on Gavin Lux or my's the
pitcher and you don't know that yet I
know Ricky I know Mookie Betts is on his
way I know I know that you know you
trout as a layup is that maybe the
all-time player I know that lebra
there's nothing that can happen to
LeBron yeah that disappointed Korea it's
why I think Barkley and Hakeem and some
of those rookies are in a really good
spot for the next twenty year from now
and basketballs at the apex and but like
if you want to bet on I'm betting on
deer and fox that's me betting I'm
having fun I think you know but I could
be but again but I look at that as going
2-0 yeah
and so I just think people have to have
a like of course it's gonna go down the
question is are we only 20% of the way
of it going up or we 90 percent I don't
know but what I will tell you is that
gambling lessons learned I'm very
curious I have no knowledge about panini
and tops and upper deck or thinking like
how are they going to manage their
productions you know there's always the
manipulation of the one of ones and the
one of tens like you'd have to think
those play out
the biggest variables injuries look I
think I've said it 18 months ago or 15
months ago
I think Luca can be an all-time 25 best
player of all time yeah I agree he could
worry my not but like if he does yeah I
promise you this his rookie cards right
now are under priced 20 years from today
I promise
of course you know how I know that
looking at the last six eaters Jordan
rookies were under priced at the height
and the collapse of sports cards the
last time around magic Sean said and
rookie cards Magic Bird this card
grossly underpriced 15 years ago but
this super hype of the market it just
depends on a couple different variables
now you get into will SGC be bigger than
vgs and bigger than PSA in 25 years I
don't know will will prism still be PSA
does seem to have a lock I just know
that things change you know like oh or
it stays forever you by the way you know
Hoss had a lock ABC and NBC and the
Netflix came along like [ __ ] changes the
home and gardening seal of approval the
true the what was that [ __ ] thing
what was the thing that made that wines
go through the roof what was that the
magazine that was no well that's a good
one in my wine world Wine Spectator
Robert Parker like matter the most and
now they don't make they they've evolved
things change things change and sports
cards people have to get very very
concerned and be very thoughtful of what
could change for example the reason I
think stickers the time about how many
stickers do you think I bought 40 more
sure no no I don't know oh so different
fair enough
what what's the number cool like I could
be very wrong about panini stickers from
basketball in the 80s and 90s going up I
just think they will because I think
soccer is gonna matter more and when
people look back at soccer in 20 years
and look at the panini stickers being
the real one I don't know I don't know
if I think that's gonna impact this
value of stick
and stickers might become something that
people want to that was my big thesis on
Jordan stickers like the Jordan rookie
sticker I thought was underpriced
because I think it's just as hard if not
harder to greed and the same supply like
I understand why it should be so much
less but the Hobby decided and the Hobby
may decide listen to me right now
you could buy you you could buy [ __ ]
Luka rookies at a thousand in a couple
months because that's what it's at on
prism right he could go on to be a top
40 player of all time super popular 2012
to 20 year run it locks in but what if
the hobby in 20 years decides that optic
was their actual rookie this is this is
where I'm going so I think it's just
everyone has to play their portfolios
and buy wait what if you're just a
collector and you don't give a [ __ ] then
buy raw hoops yeah like if you just want
to collect buy raw good what do you
think about I mean so they I like to
only buy all I try to buy greatest you
know it's just something that I just I
don't I just really the raw I mean it's
such a discrepancy in price I mean or
even if I get more great and why would
you not I mean
you know you have a $10 base card you
know raw and then you can your grade
this thing and it gets a tenth of PSA
and it's worth 200 I mean I'm not I'm
not I'm not I'm not good enough yet to
look through eBay listing stock
excellence then calm see listing and
know if I'm looking at a 9 or 10 and
probably will never get there if I was
still in high school I would have
[ __ ] only done that because I
wouldn't heal my [ __ ] cuz I got D's and
F's they were too focused on the whole
time I would have become as good as
graters because I would have been
[ __ ] focused on that and all I would
do is go to shows and look at eBay
zoomed in pictures and by tens raw and
slab them I just don't have that skill
set and I don't think I have that
ability right now because I don't have
enough time to get good at it and so I'm
gonna play the premium on the 15 year
old me who's gonna buy them for raw and
slab them and make a huge arbitrage on
me and I'm gonna make arbitrage is on
all these theories that I think yeah my
take is I'm [ __ ] pissed and I don't
have the time or the skill to do it cuz
I'd only buy raw and
the [ __ ] out of it well that's what I do
I'm [ __ ] impressed um I do suffered a
group and you know I feel like [ __ ] so
three years I cut them you know No hell
yeah you know just like just like I'm an
outsider in people's opinions even
though I grew up in it I'm an outsider
but I see things that nobody in the card
world can see because that's who I am in
marketing and human behavior outside of
it I'm coming up with hot takes like the
panini sticker thing like the rest like
I'm seeing [ __ ] that people don't see
cuz that's where I'm [ __ ] great at
that's why I invested in Facebook
Twitter and Tumblr before anybody saw it
that's why I [ __ ] win that's why I
take photos with [ __ ] rappers that
nobody's heard of in and two years later
their biggest in the game that's what
I'm [ __ ] good at you got a brother
thank you so much keep going love that
dude fire away some rapid fire wow I
think whoever asked that question smart
I've been looking at Larry Walker rookie
cards out of 10 I think that supply and
demand if all these 40 year old dads
come back in all of a sudden 84
Mattingly's and 86 you know Reggie
White's and I think there's a huge I
haven't done the full homework but one
of my new hypothesis is junk wax PSA
tens BG s 9.5 FCC tens I just haven't
done enough homework on how much
quantity is out there and how much
perception of demand do I think will be
there but there will be an uptick in
demand I just don't know how egregious
the supply is is there a million
Mattingly's is you know how many are
sitting raw haven't been graded yet I
mean these are Cunha and Luke Hood
numbers are gonna go through the roof
over the next [ __ ] couple months like
cool then it's 8,000 now what about one
at 16,000 in a month cool I'm excited
about optic Luka at a thousand I have a
funny feeling it's about 3,000 and next
month or two or three or four so that's
what I'm looking at
give me one more and then Lew will come
in Wow
I'm I think NASCAR has got a very small
niche and I'm sure NASCAR and many other
sub things have their little markets
it's not something I'm passionate or
knowledgeable enough to answer you have
a question yeah yeah there's fake art
and coins there's fake Supremes and
Yeezys the trust in these three
companies is the whole game which is why
when we hear about people trimming cards
that are older and like submitting them
and getting big great like that's a
dangerous thing because of the trust
that's how PS a or b gs or FCC or a
fourth player or a technology that comes
around that doesn't use human beings and
just scans it inevitably with the way
technology is going if you told me in
seven years a company came along it
doesn't run by humans you insert it it
is 100 percent figuring out cardboard
arbitrage and all this and it guarantees
that it's not fake and we all believe
that's better that kills all three of
these companies and all of a sudden I'm
submitting my you know this and it's
coming back at seven point three and I'm
like I like you know like [ __ ] changes
of course it can be fake a human being
decides we've trusted these companies to
be better than the masses but there's
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that could
happen it's humans it's why I hate the
Olympics a humans judging it so I hate
reviews and companies so humans judging
it but that's the way the world works
until a computer comes along and takes
away the human element we're gonna
always debate if the companies are good
at grading or not so I'm not the most
educated in swimming so let me start by
saying that but very simply super old
cards from 1948 some people will
actually go in with a razor I guess and
like yeah like 1/10 of an inch which
makes the corner go for them fluffy to
like tighter and if a human on the other
side can't see it they'll grade it a
five instead of a four or a seven
instead of a four and that can change
the price value enormous Lee it's a very
very very scary thing that you know you
have to trust that
government which has been paying
attention to this more and the companies
are policing themselves PSA BG s aka
Beckett and SGC and then even the
smaller players are the ones that are
thinking about getting into the game
they have to realize no different than
then the Wine Spectator no different
than anything else in the world the
people that grade comic books this world
I'm sure has the same thing I'm less
educated but like largely like it's
you're only as good as your your actual
truth that Pete PSA goes out of business
if everybody stops believing them so
they don't want it to happen but humans
are on the other side humans can be
bought a basketball Ref
through games right like the integrity
that'sa widest petros band like gambling
on the games
the Astros thing the Patriots like all
this stuff is about how much do you
respect the thing Olympic judges have
you seen what the Russian judges have
done to the glass fifty years we live in
a society that's flawed with humans and
you know just figuring out where if that
plays out like that's way above my
opinion but like older cards there's
some playing the new stuff it's a lot
easier because all this comes out of the
factory in a much better place there's
no reason to do that
things that are 70 [ __ ] years old 80
years old and there's listen a 10 of
this is $50,000 a nine is nine thousand
that's a forty one thousand dollar swing
that's gonna lead to people doing bad
things just like at everything gambling
and every you don't think there's [ __ ]
shady people right now trying to
convince kids in college basketball to
throw games why do you think gambling is
so scary so there's always I mean bad
acting Wall Street these [ __ ]
you know like there's there's but what
percentage at what and to me I'm
unemotional like like to me it's like if
a company if all three of these rating
companies disappear then that's what
needed to be done
for the greater good like that's what
can happen
people buy fake use these everyday human
real-life cards are just like every
other thing fake old fake diamond rings
fake art look Alex yeah no this is Gary
Vaynerchuk gary was uh like this good
bro how are you I'm doing great I'm
watching the live stream live uh
basically putting information into the
for my trading card score just trying to
relays my value that's really nice thank
you for that I know there's a bunch of
discord groups that are really rocking
rolling yeah it's been a lot of fun just
participating just trying to help like
them the new investor or collectors just
we're more of a hobby it excites one of
the reasons the reasons why I wanted to
do this today is there's so many people
getting into the hobby because of me and
because of many other people besides me
and what I've noticed from a small group
of Mike my followers is some of them are
just jumping in without doing any
education without any knowledge
they're like Gary B look what I bought
them like they're buying like a seventh
tier grading companies card I'm like no
no no so this has been a good there's an
exciting couple hours for me they're
like really help keep the conversation
going I encourage a lot of the people
that follow me to go on Twitter there's
so many people that have been in the
game longer than me like you're gonna
have their points of view but they have
tons of historic context and I'm excited
about where the Hobby can go what can I
answer for you about what all these
Lucca Bates cards just like skyrocket in
value like double triple like a base
card will be worth like six seven
hundred dollars now meanwhile like you
get a red and blue or green or other
parallel for almost the same price or
less even so I was wondering if you
think that some of those parallels are
rarer version three cards are going to
see the same proportionate increase in
value as the basis will just take longer
or will be I don't I don't I don't think
so when you look at other industries
when a mass injection of people comes in
their financial status doesn't allow
to buy the super premium as much of the
entry so I think bass will outpace the
super premium because it's awfully hard
to buy an $8,000 Luka I I would argue
the reason I'm starting to buy tops
regular and hoops is that it even has to
go lower than prison because guess what
a $700 single card of Luca Donna CH
presume is not what the average human
being is going to be jumping into right
but you think there will be a percentage
of the new masses that come in we'll get
more educated yes yes I yes but I do not
believe over the long term with a heavy
influx of demand that you'll ever get
the super premium to grow as much
because of the Ford ability and the risk
factor so it super premium they grow on
like a normal trend line I think I think
more than a normal tread line because
just the massive influx but to your
point of where you're going not
potentially as great as some of the base
no but brother what we've been talking
about today is like what if optic
becomes it not prism what if what if SGC
becomes the play not PSA what if like
there's a lot of [ __ ] variables that
were nothing bro I'm like so scared that
I'm right about the stickers like I'm
looking at the panini stickers ions more
than the base prisms I haven't bought
any for disclosure but I've been like
literally last two nights almost pulling
the trigger of wrapping up all the prism
PSA 10 stickers for Zion on panini
stickers that as you know nobody in the
Hobby gives a [ __ ] about yet right I
mean yeah listen me too for the most
part I've only gotten hot on tops
regular and because before was top
screwing during that era and optic
really in the last month because I'm
like oh [ __ ] Lucas were 35 to 70 dollars
now they're 600 like the normal person
that wants to get in for a thousand
bucks it was one thing to buy 30 Lucas I
mean if you spend $1,000 when I was
yelling about Lucca 35 bucks
and bought 30 of them you have $18,000
yeah I'm nuts over the end of summer it
was like $80 then like I just can't
believe it
they couldn't couple what I'm worried
about is that we all kind of common
sense of like oh [ __ ] is this gonna go
down and again don't let Luka drop 52 in
Game seven on prime-time you know where
it's going you see what a hobby SAP like
this summer this I mean again Corona
there's a million things that can happen
in life
every anything can happen by the way
back Toto is answering Dustin tomorrow
the FBI may come out and say 35% of PSA
cards are fake guess what that's gonna
collapse the market I don't know I'm not
Nostradamus but here's what I know most
things aren't crazy most things follow a
certain path and this summer cars are
going to be white-hot and the NBA Finals
are going to be like a [ __ ] day
trading magnet like Luca drops 18 in the
first quarter and I'm worrying about
what happens how do you peg because
everyone just [ __ ] on tilt their time
worrying about like the micro trend
corrected up I'm looking at the big
picture like overtime like oh but oh by
the way
oh by the way yes brother I'm not more
volatile if you look at the last nine
years this is why I'm holding in my hand
right now Kobe and [ __ ] Gretzky and
Hulk Hogan and magic and bird over the
next thirty years I feel great about
that I'm not worried about if once I've
got 20% of my energy worried about Juan
Soto Pete Alonzo and a Cunha to make
baseball more interesting to me to flip
at the national that's 20% I'm worried
that that's not everybody else's 100%
and that's how they're gonna get burned
yeah at the same token I think giannis
and Luca put me my opinion potentially
our top 25 players of all time I think I
think Kevin Durant comes back next year
and goes ballistic in the New York
market
or you get hurt again and be and then
it's completely collapses yeah listen I
wish I grew up with pokemons if I was
giving everybody advice if you [ __ ]
love Pokemon lotto there because you
have no risk of Pikachu getting hurt I
like my old Pokemon cards it's great in
some of them and then those that
consider does more of like my phone
investments has a more long-term and to
me because I don't like Pokemon that way
to me that's LeBron right like I would
be dumbfounded if LeBron is not $20,000
in 20 years I'd be shocked
I'm just you know by the way flah Bron
with the title I'm scared [ __ ] bro if
[ __ ] Bron Bron wins the title this
year it's gonna get I don't I mean
people gonna cry that if they had the
means that they didn't buy it at 7,500
and the reason of the in buy it was
because it was a 1050 in April right it
was like right around mid-february and I
think I've just been astounded at how
it's gone from like you know a thousand
two thousand two seventy six and I'm
wondering if that like where it's gonna
be after a loss for several years was
like I should just hold that for like a
decade long brother I'm telling you
right now I would hold LeBron in
perpetuity
basketballs go before you and I will die
before basketballs not a popular sport
during our lifetime yeah I think the bra
might end up being the president United
States one day like LeBron is showing
post basketball energy that I don't know
where LeBron ends up that'd be some [ __ ]
if LeBron becomes president we clip this
on whatever to the [ __ ] Instagram of
for 21 years from now is bro if he wins
this title he's gonna push over like bro
if he wins this title it's gonna matter
yeah
so cool man thank you all right
what are some of that Jackie Robinson
rookies Jordan I think Jordan rookie is
$100,000 card in the white heat moment
it's at 50 now I'm less into the one of
ones auto stuff like I'm not educated
enough in some of the stuff that my
friend like Adam rode like you know like
it's really focused on like those LeBron
Jordan pet like I'm just not educated
enough yet in the 90s basketball like
rare [ __ ] that I that's going crazy I
like oldest [ __ ] [ __ ] you know cream
rookies will chain 61 flea or basketball
obsessed with master rookies Jerry West
rookies Wilt Chamberlain rookies I
haven't started studying but like I'm a
little hey it's Gary what's your name
kiba yeah kiba yeah how are you good how
are you I'm well what can I answer for
you I'm like supreme you know like I
understand Cuba and I was like looking
into kind of getting into this sports
car
so why what would you like on then why
well obviously I saw like with you you
said that the the honest rookie was go
up like mm like three years but it went
in up like mm my three months so so me
being kind of like are you aiming to do
this so so with supreme and sneakers
when you when did you first get into it
like beginning of last year maybe and
and have you and have you been able to
get yourself educated and now like the
dumb [ __ ] you made mistakes on when you
first got into supreme fake sort of
wrong stuff do you feel like you're a
lot do you feel like you're a lot
smarter at it oh yeah
good next yeah do you like sports yeah
yeah
what's your talent I love that well well
then you're in good shape brother take
the next 50 hours of reading you know
blowouts forums
Twitter bunch of Instagram accounts
obviously I'm putting out content like
get really [ __ ] educated completed
items on eBay stock ex you know buy and
sell prices go fifty hours deep go to a
shop go to a local card show find three
to ten rabbis aka mentors that you just
find on Twitter through conversations
get real real real educated and then
start buying it because I'm telling you
right now basketball a couple things you
heard what I said I'm buying eighty
percent of my stuff long-term 20 percent
gambling how do I think about that
LeBron long-term deer and Fox gambling
lebra giannis I think you know you need
to tie it all to get crazy but he's so
goddamn good and so young like you know
so that I would call that an 80% locked
in 20% gamble because he does need a
title but like Harry it's kind of locked
in everyone's forgotten about him a
little because he's hurt I like that
with gambling but like if you what's
your favorite basketball team mmm right
now on some bandwagon [ __ ] maybe where
do you live bro you need to be a [ __ ]
Spurs man or a rockets fan or a [ __ ]
Dallas fan where you a Spurs fan when it
was [ __ ] going good no I respect that
so weird of [ __ ] did the pelicans come
from LeBrons not on the pelicans though
you decide to take sion for next yeah I
respect that
so listen brother yeah what you need to
do is get really so I had somebody hit
me up that is a music manager and told
me about 50 Koosman rookies I didn't
even know he was into it he manages one
of the biggest hip-hop artists there's
like a cold text the other night I got
super pumped cuz that's like an
interesting take right if they're gonna
make a run there's gonna be all eyes on
that team obviously LeBron Anthony Davis
are obvious but what if cooze goes crazy
like I love that kind of [ __ ] that might
be fun for you because you're a Lakers
fan what what I promise you cards do
like I've watched more [ __ ] Atlanta
Hawks highlights and like box scores
like I care about I literally every
night because I think Devonte Graham has
upside long-term look at the Charlotte
but box score every night to see what
Graham's doing if you love basketball
I think basketball cards both modern for
all the youngsters do you like ham
radish do you not but if you really want
to be safe if you're just a flipper
you're gonna have to add some patience
because I like you over time to get into
some of the classic Schick 8687 Fleer
you know you know build up some of the
old basketball stuff 72 tops dr. J I
think is unbelievably underpriced that's
the [ __ ] doctor you know like so you
know get educated fifty hours and then
put your toe in I do think you would
make more money in the next four years
on sports carts than you would on
sneakers and supreme I believe that
trends about to happen that I do believe
talk to you thank you yes of course
arjan dough and story your top 25
baseball players but the Colorado effect
hurts their market because people think
their stats are inflated in Colorado if
Jon morant was a Knick his prices would
be up even more because New York's a
bigger market one of the reasons I like
Bellinger so much and is because with
the addition of Mookie Betts and I think
Gavin Lux is a real player I agree with
Lou that the pitching might be a little
bit suspect this year the Walker Buehler
zabi stand like will be interesting to
see what else you know if they pop in La
it's [ __ ] LA that does matter like
now with basketball we've seen the real
hot players if they're really great they
usually go to a big market team so I'm
if I'm thing about Zion now but I'm
thinking about him in five years and he
comes to New York LA you know these kind
of things the market effects things not
to mention little things like I think
Anthony Rendon is about to have a big
year cuz with trout and some of the
other beasts he's surrounded in that
lineup like I think he might have a
really big year and I think he's a top
player that people don't think about
anyone a championship last year how does
that you know
although taani clicks like you're yes
the [ __ ] team matters a lot
good questions good these words eSports
I you know I'd love to see I you know
I'm an owner of a Minnesota Call of Duty
team minority owner with the will steer
people that owned the Vikings I'm not I
have no information zero towards you
know whether cod or any other League
there are fortnight cards out it seemed
like they were pretty mass-produced
there's a lot of them but then also if
the man goes up in fortnight's a fifty
year title maybe there are under price
there was a lot of like wrestling cards
may do but the demand like so I don't
know yet
but I am excited long-term about eSports
I do believe eventually there'll be one
that really locks in a leak that will go
with a big-time producer whether it's
leaf who does some really interesting
stuff whether that's you know tops
whether it's upper deck whether that's
you know panini that will then become
the meaningful card and then that will
be fun and then you'll make bets on
whether you think it's you know Booga or
an inch of scale or you know what I mean
what else you just have to overpay with
eBay shipping costs like if you live in
Sweden and you're watching right now
like buy it and pay extra big like if
you like you have no other options like
what are you gonna do it's just how can
you get them just a ship I mean we is
you know we buy a lot of stuff in Canada
comes down here I bought stuff in Europe
I mean but forty dollars shipping
doesn't bother me if I think something's
going through the roof and I'm getting
at the right price it's just business
I'm not emotional about paying it in the
shipping or if I'm paying in the you
know again using I mean when I when I
made the content about buying Yanis at a
buck 80 buck 20 people like oh it's when
I got the 300 kids like the Gary FIFA
like Larry 2600 now I'm sure everybody
who didn't buy it at 600 when they
thought it was so over fellated buy meat
or something else I'm sure they're
[ __ ] sad it has I'm not [ __ ]
making him dominate on the court he's
completely unblockable he's an awesome
human being he's charismatic as [ __ ]
he's also like [ __ ] still young as
[ __ ] he scares the [ __ ] out of me if you
told me he wins five in a row I'm like
okay
remember what happened one like taxes
started going on eBay I got so pissed
and then becomes normal right like I
wasn't pumped to pay taxes like but but
like I don't
I love paying my taxes as long as
everybody else to pay the same I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm buying a couple things
raw I bought a bunch of Gavin Lux tops
raw somebody gave me a good tip it was
like hey look at the way somebody sells
raw if they sell a bunch of graded and a
bunch of raw they probably looked at it
and they know that they're not tense if
somebody's just loves to open packs and
sells raw all day you might have a
higher chance of them being tens in
there that's the game I'm about to learn
I'm glisten I'm no expert I'm going
through the trials and tribulations -
I'm buying raw when I think somebody
like I think Gavin listen I love Gavin
LOX
I think is gonna be a real player so I
can't buy I don't want to buy the
Bauman's I want to buy the tops because
I think there's a moment happening with
tops closing the gap on his Bowman
prices so the new tops comes out the
only thing I can buy is raw right now so
that's why I'm buying raw there's a I
bought a bunch of Jaron Jackson's last
night or the night before so I'm buying
some of the young players that I'm not
just sure just yet they're at like the
75% of like a little small little hedge
right I bought a ton of knocks last year
because I thought we're getting Durant
and Kyrie and it was gonna be awesome
that has not worked out but those raw
but I'm glad I bought those raw because
that was a way for me to head you're not
get destroyed right you know so a little
bit and I think over time is I say
sustain in this if you know if I keep
tripling down on this you know I might
get into I might get it educated by
accident on Raw a little bit and might
find myself but I'm still not good
enough at knowing what a centered raw
tennis
I haven't done personal homework on
nines yet we had a great discussion
earlier is it gonna be second tier
companies like the lower-cost product or
is it gonna be nines but I will say this
everything is gonna go up with the
amount of demand that's coming it's very
hard to lose right now unless of injury
the way to lose right now buying cards
actual carts is picking the wrong guy a
Baker Mayfield that did not work out
going into last year Baker was exciting
you know and like he did not have the
season he wanted so you lost money but
for the most part it's like a lot of
like there's just so much in demand and
again to remind everybody like me
putting out a tweet or a blog post or a
podcast or this it was the breakers on
YouTube it was Father's getting back
into it it was some of the sneaker I got
back into it cuz kids and sneaker heads
got into it and I saw a lot of YouTube
videos that were getting real beaut I've
loved cards since I was a kid I never
wanted like I never talked about it
heavy before the last 20 years I got
back in cuz it's obvious to me and I
like making good decisions with my time
and finances and I like telling other
people about things to debate but I want
them to be educated enough students give
me one more while he does any tough
questions I mean there's so many people
there's like hundreds of people that
hate me in the sports card world I want
to get a tough question in I'm like why
do I like it I'm getting $0.00 for us
you see
I like black cases like it's not super
good you know when SEC did the 88 like
it's not super on the record or give a
[ __ ] about tops panini SGC PSA and Beca
combined if they all die tomorrow I'm
pumped
yo its Gary
holy [ __ ] Gary what's good bro dude I've
been trying to get on with you for like
over a year been trying to talk to you
my son and my son turned me on you he's
20 we got a couple businesses together
that we just started out after after a
falling-out with another family business
and and we're
a lot of sports cart stuff he turned you
onto that we've been doing pretty decent
with it and my oh shucks can't believe
I'm talking to you my biggest question
is is you know on the Nemean step what
would your what's your take on panini
okay great question what's your name
Shiloh real pleasure so the tops now in
panini instant stuff I've not looked at
at all I've just spent 0 minutes and 0
seconds on it I have no knowledge on the
secondary market values
I like the thesis I've also spent no
time on the tops blockchain product I
just haven't figured out my thoughts yet
cuz I can't get to everything because I
run a thousand person company and have a
family and I have a million things going
on obviously this industry and this
genre has got my attention a lot over
the last two years and especially over
the last hundred days but I don't have a
great answer shadow I apologize it
doesn't feel like it's super hot it
doesn't feel like people are gravitas
things it on the flip side much much
just like stickers or SGC or optic what
don't we see maybe there's something
there because the inventory levels are
very low and one could argue long term
from supply and demand but you need the
band but you need the man what's that
yadi what's good bro have you started
getting into the cards I need to talk to
I'm gonna call you in a way home
so Shiloh I think that I think that uh I
don't know is the real answer but I will
say that anything that has low supply is
always in play to pop but it needs
demand right yeah and that's what I was
curious your thoughts because you know
we've been buying you know Levi's quite
a bit you know we actually started about
a year ago and I actually got a on a
panini prison we we pulled a a Lucas
autograph and ended up selling that's
what we're buying so many cards we know
that's you know that's here you know
selling that's like 400 bucks how much
like how much is immediate how much is
it nav oh [ __ ] look too great
yep turning turning cards into money is
never a horrible thing you just look a
lot of my friends sold their Facebook
stock at $48 you know then it got up to
220 they're sad you know like some
people want it for 220 the other day and
now it's down cuz
I got a look today but like I'm sure
it's Wallops like everything else so
it's very hard to capture the market at
the right time what I keep trying to
tell everybody is the mackerel market is
about to about to explode I think that
we're looking at 1/10 1/100 of the
demand that we have right now in the
next 24 months as as has news programs
start to cover this as people like yacht
lil yachty and like way cooler [ __ ]
more important cultural people than me
get into this when some massive sneaker
head makes a blog post that they sold
all 1 million dollars of their sneakers
and now have bought all sports cards and
complex covers that like uh like 137
p.m. a media company I hired I own is
about to write about sports cards every
day like I just think there's a lot more
coming yes we've been fined the [ __ ] out
of it mean ESS to despoil record Big
Chief and sweep we live in Kansas and
you know we've been chief phantoms all
the kids did you buy mom like if you
bought mahomes heavy a year ago you
crushed yeah yeah I've got some home
stuff and then I bought a bunch of you
know I write a lot of that even one out
of tens
yeah like sets and and everything else
just because I know you know obviously
limited there was limited things when I
was like Oh peachy baseball was the
hottest [ __ ] thing in 1992 it was
quote-unquote limited its worthless
today the thing that I keep telling
everybody is buy the most iconic hundred
players across all the sports and then
and then be very thoughtful if you think
limited is enough because again if
people don't care about panini in ten
years or twenty years we're all gonna
get caught so have a smart strategy
which is why I want people to bet on
players that are foolproof has eighty
percent of their investment Mike Trout
brainy you know like these things really
a basketball because I think it's the
macro and high in soccer Messi Ronaldo
you know with a hedge on up-and-coming
stars like Felix and and and Mumbai pay
so I think there's a lot of cool stuff
to bet on hey we do we do me one quick
favor yes sir my my son's twenty years
old he's a he's got a great head on
he's an entrepreneur I mean he's he
gives it all the work seven days a week
you know 10 to 18 hours a day you know
getting artists our new businesses going
and you have the you know he's such a
[ __ ] workhorse and he's such a huge
fan of yours would you do me a favor
would you would you give me shout out
his name's Damon good Damon good what's
up it's Gary Vee keep going brother you
literally literally got 80 more years of
aiming for happiness and hustle so
congratulations I can't wait to meet you
in real life I just had a great chat
with your dad and I can't wait to meet
one day come to the national antics city
I'm gonna be there the entire week oh
yeah I need you to go to the National
will you go in will you go in late July
early August to the National Atlantic
City like will you make those plans the
National is not paying me give a [ __ ]
about the National to national goes out
of business BG s SPC VSA tops panini
Leaf give a [ __ ] paid for two tables
I'll see you there thank you you got a
brother it's so fascinating to people
that they would think if they knew
anything about my life and know
everything I've got going on the thought
of like running a pump and dump
arbitrage four hundred thousand dollars
in sports like yeah that's why you guys
are laughing cuz you know my actual life
and people are just so siloed in like
being the gatekeepers of their thing as
if you get to decide if people somebody
DM either like you have to collect to be
in this I'm like what are you talking
about
why do I have to collect that's like
thing you have to wear sneakers or you
have to like look at the art every day
or you have to like eat sushi every day
to be a fan of suit like what are you
talking about who the [ __ ] made you God
there's people that can flip there's
people that can collect there's a
million things you can do the hypocrisy
people are watching people somebody's
like you're pumping and then I go look
at their least tweet and they're like
bow Bichette by a now like I'm like what
are we talking about here the hypocrisy
is [ __ ] unbelievable I'll see you all
in 20 [ __ ] years for 98% of people
that are razzing me I was in the sports
cards before they were [ __ ] popping
out of their mommy so I don't need your
[ __ ] [ __ ] let's keep it going buddy
god
that's been really interesting cuz the
markets getting annihilated and cards
are caught like I'm like oh [ __ ] like
what like I'm in a weird spot like [ __ ]
should I sell some my cards to buy
Facebook and Netflix right now cuz
they're wildly under pranic is that a
better art but I'm like I literally had
this talk with myself what a weekend I'm
like no I actually think LeBrons are
gonna go up more than whenever I hit the
bottom of [ __ ] Facebook and like I
just don't think people see it the way I
see it I really think that every high
net worth individual at sixty years old
that today is 28 to 40 is gonna have a
LeBron rookie in their home and I think
that's gonna get expensive Andy Warhol
went up this is art for our culture I
know it that's why I like oversized love
right think about this hanging in
somebody what's good bro hey Gary what's
your name yeah Adam what's good so I had
DN blue a question actually about the
nineties era like shocker hmm so
basically like with with that error like
there's so many so many different cards
and so much and so much supply of those
cards right exactly that's my theory my
theory about those cards in general was
that like
I think the rand blank cops are going to
be good in the long term and what tense
what ends up is gonna happen is that
like new collectors are gonna come in
and they're gonna see cops and they're
gonna say oh well tops must be the brand
that a you get right is that somebody
you wouldn't think about that I don't
know if that's true I think tops is an
iconic brand and I and I think long-term
I grew up during the year or Don Russ
was more popular than tops and then
upper deck and leave for more popular
than tops and here we are and tops is
here so I think in baseball there's a
lot of historic value you know I don't
know I mean look I think bean team
shacks are probably stadium club bean
team shacks are probably gonna end up
being very under priced because of it
I think you have to put deploy real
economics against this real
tried-and-true global economics meaning
supply and demand matters there is a lot
more tops regular shacks than there are
bean team shacks plus the hobby has
decided the bean team Shaq is the rookie
on the flip side
to your point and I made it earlier I do
think as the hobby gets 10x more popular
the lower end is got a chance to go up
even more than the high end and so you
know does a beam team thing go from 1500
to 3000 while the regular tops I don't
know what the regular Top Shot goes for
right now but does that go from 30 to
300 10x versus 2x or 3x that's gonna be
a very interesting debate I think what I
like about the lower-end going up faster
than the higher end is the majority
people who are watching right now if
they want to make a bet are in a better
likely chance to buy ten tops PSA 10
Shaq rookies or fleet I like the floor a
lot because the color scheme makes it
hard for that to be a 10 grade but
that's not here not there I bought 10
floor at that point right more less 13
maybe I remember I bought it once I was
all excited cuz it's like gold tree like
it was kind of like these are heart like
the white stuff doesn't bang up as easy
on the like the great like nonetheless
getting a little nerdy here but yeah I
like that you can buy 10 shacks and they
10x instead of you can't afford ten
beams and the beams only three acts
similar to the prism high-end that we
talked about earlier makes sense yes 19
feet long cars on instagram has given me
the tip about that and I actually had DM
view about that one the one with the
black jersey right yes yes yes so I
bought a couple of those over the summer
upper 30s and that I just recently sold
two of them firm 2 total for 170 so the
Shaq car is even even the one if Shaq if
Shaq was during the pre era of the junk
wax era or the posterior he'd be some of
the most expensive cards because he's a
cultural phenomenon right come to your
point if basketball become like listen
Shaq earlier the junk wax era is it
under price I would argue Shaq is a
running take as one of the best junk wax
era cards to buy because the demand may
even outpace that enormous amount of
supply yeah I agree
oh please I know this was it
the Bowman Chrome first Bowman rookies
are starting to either be less than the
regular top European like your movie
better looking better
how many T is more expensive than the
mookie betts bone and chrome cards I'm
seeing it too for so long I know I'm not
sure by the way where and don't forget
I've been watching for two years and I
only thought Bowman Bowman Bowman bro
this is what I'm telling you when a lot
more people get involved thus hobby and
the way they decided things is gonna
change it's very simple if there's
30,000 people into something and their
collective energy decides something
because that's what a hobby is and a
market is and now there's 400,000 people
in it there's a chance that things will
shift I've been blown away by that
dynamic like even when I was a kid
Mariano Rivera 92 is like Bowman was
more powerful than tops right now all of
a sudden to your point I'm seeing more
of a push towards the tops considered
rookie whether that's an update a series
to a series one that's why I bought a
bunch of Gavin Lux raw like I don't
notice to tell you like yes I see that
happening - is that a micro five-second
trend or does that become the trend
again I don't know I'm just trying to
tell the collective hobby be prepared
for new things to happen if hundreds of
thousands of people get involved yeah
totally great and then one other
question hopefully this will be my last
question so what do you think Oh the
answer in prism so let's really be like
Luka so there's like three main ones but
like the insert weren't those things
numbered solo I'm undereducated on 90s
basketball inserts it's one of the
police's I want to get educated on
I know NAT and others like a really
heavy on that that shit's super hot it's
really expensive
I'm very under educated on it but
correct me if I'm wrong I'm asking you
if you know those things were like
number 275 or 200 like I these prism
numbers I think are far greater no I
don't know the the numbering stuff
I just know that like I'm talking to
people who collect those types of cars
like they've told me that the 90s insert
was much more popular than the regular
regular looking which like I felt like
I've been looking into PSA numbers for
some of the inserts and they're like in
the in the 200s but like obviously if
there are any if ther number - like 75
for the 90s cards like that's obviously
a different but or different but that's
kind of what I was looking at recently
at least it's a really interesting take
brother and like honestly I'm excited
cuz you're gonna make me look at it
right now like yeah I mean I think it's
an interesting conversation I just have
no I have no knowledge of the Zion and
Luca inserts are a good way to look
versus the base I just haven't started
that process but hearing you articulated
I'm like huh I promise you that I'll be
taking a flight in a couple of months
and I'll remember this call and then
I'll spend four and a half hours flying
to back from LA to New York literally
just doing homework on that mat I think
that's an important part that a lot of
people are missing right now that are
jumping in I did hundreds of hours of
homework going to shows reading forums
reading Twitter following Instagram
accounts looking at completed eBay and
stock X numbers at nausea before I even
started coming up with hypothesis or
tweets there they're willing to just
spend it on anything if people are
spending like you're saying this hangs a
hundred hours doing the research late
I'm yours tons of opportunity and I
think that's maybe something that other
people in the hobby don't think that
there is what they think that there's
only one way to make money or to collect
these I don't think that's okay I think
that's right and I don't think you me or
anybody else no matter how long or how
short you've been collecting owns the
Hobby or the flip market it's audacious
to think that yeah yeah and they'll be
and look this happened to me like I got
into the fall I was super hyped then I
got into the fall and I had to replace
my head of every discipline at
vaynermedia
I had a lot of things going on in my
life busy the jet season like I'm always
gonna be less loud about the hobby
September to December because I'm busy
like so it just goes into pockets to
like I'll always not make as much
opportunity for myself in basketball
because I'm too busy September first on
and there's a lot of fun action to be
had in September and October prior to
the basketball season I've just remits
to know that to be true totally great
yes you are you trying to articulate I
think the best that you can like the
stuff that you like and I think it's not
a coincidence that stuff that you like
just happens to be correct like this
stuff that goes up in value I don't take
it I don't think the two are related but
I think that like when you are saying
that you like this card it's already on
its way up is that kind of what do you
think about that I think it's so damn
obvious like people are making fun of me
at both sides of their mouth that are
mad at me they're like this [ __ ]
guy's manipulating the market and then
three tweets later they're like dude
he's not a [ __ ] genius he's just
talking about the cards that we're all
talking about I'm like so which one is a
dick you're saying at nausea if Luka
becomes Paul George injury you're gonna
lose a fuckload of money if Luca
becoming ever grows even lose a fuckload
of money long like yeah like I'm sorry
that I think LeBron James was a good bet
no no it's not a roll up and you're
exciting me because I appreciate you
articulating it I read all these
comments and I am a lot of love for
these guys and dealers and like a lot of
people are mean to me on Twitter
publicly but then DM me nicely or I see
them a Chosen are nice and I'm like hey
I get it like there's an establishment
to everything when somebody's been
buying up three properties in DUMBO and
a big real estate person comes and buys
more there's some mad when you love the
band and then they get big and everybody
loves them you get mad like I understand
the human dynamics it's just that don't
make up stuff like people are making up
stuff people like this guy's pumping and
dumping I would sold [ __ ] have you
at all like saying that you're just not
selling anything right me no because
brother here because no no brother the
answer is no but I'll answer any
question how many Zion's you have none
like like here's here's why if I don't
like the way Cody Bellinger is playing I
want to be able to sell it what am I
gonna put myself in concrete and say I'm
never selling like I don't [ __ ] know
like if tomorrow I'm like in 1993 I was
at a [ __ ] firehouse and New Jersey
doing a show and decided because of what
I'm good at as a human that the card
market was about to collapse sold my
entire collection of four dealers and
put all that money into comic books and
toys I want to be able to do that in
three and a half I say this all the time
I like snapchat when snapchats good I
like tick-tock one tick tocks good i
like facebook when facebook's good i
like cards right now because it's good
and it's gonna be good
I'm also gonna sell them if I don't
think it's gonna be good I'll publicly
say it I'm not gonna quietly try to sell
off my thing and then like like I'm like
there's no hot bro you know this there's
no hiding anyway everyone's like oh
you're getting loud now no not I'm
reacting to what's happening let me tell
you what was happening I was I've been
buying I'm buying but what ended up
happening was people figure out my
account I'm not hiding
Madison sports car right I'm just buying
and people are then creating discord
groups and group chats and what's up
stats and ticks are saying Gary's buying
this and they're buying it up and then
and then some people like oh you're
quietly buying and then promoting I'm
like okay I don't want to do that
because that would suck right like when
I said I think Pete Alonzo might be
under price to be it's a bunch of homers
I had 20 help me here Lou yeah seven ten
brother right brother
I get paid $250,000 to give a speech I
attended I had 10 Pete Alonzo cards at
30 bucks apiece
like I'm not trying to pump them to 70
and sell them make $400 and ruin my name
then I'm a con artist
what is the Madi of paper you what is a
[ __ ] matter with people I I am I have
a hot take Mark McGwire and Barry Bonds
went up a fuckload Peter Lanza with 53
homers as a
New York met who's a nice kid whose epic
with fans when I watched it epic with
fans he's a nice kid
he had 53 [ __ ] home runs do you
understand what what happened to Pete
Alonso hits 60 home runs this year and
the hobby is 10x hotter it was giannis
and Luca TEDx it's 60 he's 53 last year
now by the way he's a 250 hitter and
could be [ __ ] Joey Gallo I get it he
could I'm buying baseball for one reason
the National is my Disney World trip for
the week I want to set up I want to have
stacks of cards and baseball is gonna be
on everybody's mind in the summer and if
a is on his way to 50/50 that card is
gonna be 500 at the show and if he gets
hurt it's gonna go from 250 300 down to
a buck
like that's cards that's not Gary Vee
tweeted I didn't tweet [ __ ] about Zion
it's been out of control not a tweet not
a single purchase I own zero by the way
it's not talking about giannis at $400
$500 it's gone on its way to 2,600
[Music]
looking for national treasure is
impeccable immaculate like that [ __ ] is
gonna be for rich [ __ ] people that's
gonna be on some 1% [ __ ] like national
treasures are expensive to me like that
shit's expensive man will it affect it
no because it's gonna be for the
super-rich it's gonna be for 1% the [ __ ]
is a $15,000 cases of cards who the [ __ ]
is that for you know I'm going the other
way
I'm like buying hoops Lucas yeah I mean
I started a text when you'll turn it
my next offer like what I did with
giannis on Instagram I don't know if you
were around for this when I bought like
a hundred of them but then I sold like
10 of them on Instagram because I wanted
everybody those kids bought it for me
from $180 or $200 they made a fortune my
next offer I'm giving it to you now
here's transparency my next up is gonna
be Luka hoops I started a text read that
has 10,000 people in it I'm gonna give
advice there and then I'm also gonna
offer cards once in a while that I think
fit DeLuca
I wanted them to fit the giannis model
that's what I've been thinking a lot
about if you were a kid like people were
yelling at me to selling Yanis in my
Instagram at 180 because they were 120 a
few weeks earlier every kid that bought
that for me 50 12 14 months ago ripped
me the [ __ ] off it's 2600 now right I
sold 60 Lucas at the national for 60
bucks those guys in debt in Texas Big
Ups to you guys you ripped me the [ __ ]
off just cuz I wanted to I'm gonna get
ripped off at the National cuz there I'm
not smart there I want to be a dealer
like I was a kid Full Tilt's you saw I
made up remember that Renaldo I got
murdered on I lost Alec I am my dumbest
at the National I'm like dumbest at the
National but like I'm looking I'm trying
to buy like I want to give advice I also
like action I like action I like the
idea of buying hoops Lucas for 90 and
selling them for 120 or 60 and 80 and
then selling them for 80 that makes me
excited or whatever I don't know what
the numbers are on that but like but
what did I sell what did i buy the Lucas
let's go trance what I buy Lucas for and
what are they at right now no no not
that I'm sorry not the prisms I know we
destroy that hoops 104 that I bought I
bought like a hundred like I knew I was
gonna do this little thread where I
wanted to have action cuz I love selling
[ __ ] that's why I love by the way
everybody watching if you buy wine wine
text calm the same reason I talk to my
dad's business every day on wine texts
I like commerce I like action but I want
to figure out if I'm gonna order it if
I'm gonna offer to my fans I want to do
[ __ ] like hey I really believe in this
hoops thesis let me buy for 60 let me
sell for 90 that makes me happy but I
also think there would be 200 and so my
fans are gonna be happy otherwise I get
murdered on the back end if they go down
does that make sense yeah like for table
ikuyo cunha even though I'm in
yep even though I'm in at ninety or a
hundred like by the way everybody
nailing me for pronounced pronunciations
that makes me laugh go to the wine world
for a decade when I mispronounced every
wine
it's everything I'm living right now
Adam in the sports world is everything
that I lived in the wine world I have
strengths and weaknesses pronunciation a
weakness every single Lukas right now
you know that's it so anyway like listen
I'm trying to live my life I'm trying to
leave a legacy I know I'm right about
sports cards and just like everything
that ever happened to me in wine and
social media history will be my biggest
advocate I can deal with the hate I can
deal with the push back I know that
people are spreading fake rumors left
and right I tried to go silent and just
buy and not bother anybody that didn't
work then I started being a little more
public about things I wanted that didn't
work then yes last night I put out my
buying price on Luka optic that
seemingly didn't work Lou yelled at me
this morning is like you know like you
know like I can't help it I don't know
what to do what am I supposed to live in
a [ __ ] bubble and by the way I'm
gonna be the atheist most influential
person in this game correct and I'm not
on the internet and not off the internet
and by the way wait - it's happening I'm
getting athletes hitting me up left and
right left and right wait to the
athletes start buying them to invest in
their own rookie card I don't know but
I've told every Vayner sports kid when
they've signed with us to do it it's the
ultimate flex you believe in yourself I
told Donovan Mitchell at the NBA
all-star weekend because I love that kid
to buy as many of his own rookie cards
and then take a photo with like a
thousand of them
it's just fun anyway Thank You brothers
very good yeah thanks yeah it's morally
well though any other tough like I want
to get some of the tough questions if
you got anything you got anything
millions I mean look I'm willing to be
transparent I don't need to give
everybody every goddamn thing I'm not
willing to take my pants off and be
naked like but millions big why in the
same reason that I stopped investing in
startups for three years it's because I
believe now I bought some really old
stuff really expensive my volume of cars
is not that high you know I'm not buying
thousands of these low it's been more
because I'm buying very high-end stuff
the class I'm by I'm meeting my own dogs
everything you will hear from me forever
is what I'm doing and I'll keep trying
different things like hey here's my
buying price hey here's who I think is
gonna be hot
buying silently I'm trying to figure it
out I don't know how to navigate in this
world never everything that I buy an
eBay is on Edison sports cards you can
look it up it's Madison sports card
company like um Lou please create some
color here like you know me like please
help me say something that makes sense I
don't know C's I made all the mistakes
gotta get educated I thought I was
educated I got more educated
they're just nose ions I can't believe
that the thing it's crazy people think
that you're I have a single tweet don't
have a single purchase I [ __ ] that up
I was right about the Shawn I thought he
was underrated so I bought that lot and
I [ __ ] her and they were optic which I
think are under price now potentially
listen I love sports cars I've lived my
whole life I will continue to flip I
will not
not sell in perpetuity I will not sell a
bronze I will not sell Jordans I will
not send like a Ronaldo like the magic
I'm not selling any of these Magic Bird
cards if you saw me at the National most
of my case was not selling like you
giannis that was right not selling I
bought honest there and everybody like
kids I was listening kids would sell me
honest that and they were laughing they
were like but I bought it for 600 they
thought I manipulated it from one 2600
they'd walk over a little bit I've big
time years and they're like he carries
such an idiot and they were wrong just
like the guy that bought 60 Lucas for me
for 60 bucks at the end of the show
because I love selling I love selling
I'm sorry that I'm an entrepreneur
I apologize yeah I get it we were pumped
30 to 60 but meanwhile there's 600 now I
don't know if you heard know what else
what else
tougher questions or feedback no such
thing as passive income I'm looking this
[ __ ] up every night for three hours this
is not about every night I'm spending
enormous amount of time looking the [ __ ]
up I'm doing homework I'm looking for
angles things that people don't see and
anytime I'm looking for things that
people don't see ken SGC cuz they got
cool black I think this is cry asked
[ __ ] like a hundred people that were
normal which one's cooler to you this
one so I'm like whom I wonder if that
becomes the thing when 400,000 people
come in when people start analyzing SGC
versus PSA everyone's like what's a
Harding grading company but also it's a
small company like I said it could go
out of business but as soon as I'm
looking for new angles oh you're you're
manipulating it are they paying you is
the national pain you know I [ __ ]
love baseball card shows I just want all
of you to comp I like hanging out it's
so fun you know like I don't get it like
look old Lou like I was devastated he
couldn't come right I was crushed
call you like 10 times I'm like he had a
business thing but like Atlantic City
this year whole week
who's this Jason and Jason it's Gary be
flip-flop Gary life is good bro how are
you good are you good man what's your
question my question is so a lot of new
people in the card market we did not go
through by 2008 right so what do you
think history repeats what do you think
gonna happen - card market the same
thing that happened in 2008 and happened
in 2001 and every other year I spoke
Astana
the tippy-top ship is gonna go down 20
to 40 20 to 30% max and the players that
didn't pan out the way you thought they
would are gonna collapse like crazy
which which is why 80% of my money is
going into forever
and 20% is gambling on Joe Adele or DRM
box got it where's what I'm worried
about is that everybody puts their money
even in great prospects like Juan Soto
he's still a baby yeah I think it's not
I believe that Zion is still at this
point gambling what I'm sure people that
sat through lebron will tell you is if
zombie comes LeBron this is the cheapest
that will ever be I think everyone's on
tilt right now and I do think that in
the offseason things could come down
even at cunha went to 300 down to 250
like you got to kind of watch it I do
do I believe there'll be pockets of Zion
becomes LeBron do I believe right now
that there will be still a couple of
pockets where Zions will be less than
they are right now yes I do I think
during the NBA offseason when everyone's
deciding between Daniel Jones and darn
old and Baker and do you triple down on
the homes have where does Brady end up
not the Patriots and what does that mean
and Stidham and I think our attention
will go to the month before I mean so
much of everyone's like Gary you know
baseball Bellinger I'm like all the
other baseball players are going up -
why are you mad at me like baseball goes
up the month before baseball comes out
it's
you know you know yeah just scorch and
I'm I'm not talking I'm bought Ives
owned zero yellow jizz I've tweeted zero
times about Yelich like you know like
and he's and he is the best player
potentially in baseball like I just not
excited about it
I've decided not to be excited about
Yelich from my own random purposes
I just I'm hotter the Dodgers so
Belanger and bets excite me cuz I'm hot
on the Dodgers going really really
really crazy offense hot and it's LA I
like LA more than Milwaukee sorry
I think Big Mo I think the money and new
color like LA you know so anyway
nonetheless but yes I think people like
I believe not only will be an economic
downturn where things go down I think
that there's so much heat coming that
the inevitable calm down no different
than any trade guess what
far less eight to 11 year old girls are
making slime today than they did 24
months ago right like every trend has
cycles but carts have been around for a
hundred years they've had multiple turns
long term it's a really interesting
thing and if I'm right that this is my
generations art and you're in it for the
long haul
and 80% of your [ __ ] is safe I think
it's about super safe then I would call
it middle safe Luca and Gianna's have
showed us enough that they may be middle
safe Janus mornin Luca but like I kind
of just believe in Luca and then there's
complete [ __ ] gambling in my world
that's called Sam Darnell in the air and
Fox and Juan Soto than other people's
world it's you know jaren Jackson or you
know it could be just a Trey young I
don't think is locked
you know mm-hm John Moran I think is a
really good debate they're very
expensive he's super dynamic but like
what I call him risk I would not to
mention some guys don't translate
forever you know Vince Carter and Allen
Iverson cards are very inexpensive they
did become iconic players they just
didn't grasp the javis interest paint
Manning some guys just don't take the
heart of the Hobby mm-hmm you know what
I mean yeah so I think a lot about Luca
and Rihanna's personalities versus come
why do you understand if Kauai was a
different guy how expensive that card
would be yeah because you're looking at
performance not collectability and
popularity I listen to political experts
tell me [ __ ] all the time and I keep
reminding them that the president United
States is a popularity contest yeah
Tim Duncan cards should be 40 X then if
you believe Kauai czar underpriced yeah
I'm aware
but some people are culture and some
people are not so why I'm buying
Kapernick arts culture sure yeah so
thank you brother
yep thank you so much we're not gonna
get to our greeting strategy today but
this is too good well you could be upset
only one I'm lost
hello Chris it's Gary B yeah Chris you
were by the guys after they bought the
60 Lucas for me that day Oh tops regular
excites me especially I think 2009
because that or 2012 2009
I just did this homework the other day
when tops was about to lose its license
short printing and like I love that [ __ ]
it's applying to vamp yeah I'm here
brother how are you yeah oh I am great
man
were you uh yeah are you by the guys
that bought the 60 Lucas for 60 bucks at
the national off me I was and let me
preface this I was chatting up with
Tyler Xerox and Lou and I just spent
$400 on the chippers that DC chippers
that you put up on Twitter yep
as an emotional and that meant because
she's your favorite player girl yeah no
yep and you're like hey as you see me
envisage what's about so I was like Gary
be chipper you know yep this is my first
car purchase since I was like 12 I love
that thank you change all some other
stuff and I searched I I watched the guy
do the Luca deal right yep and how much
were those because y'all said 60 earlier
I thought it was 80 but he was like yeah
man they're 80 bucks apiece
dude have a duffel bag full and here's
what his plan was he had a store he had
a store he had a store in Texas right
they had a store in Texas I think that I
think that but his plan was with this I
hope you like hey she might get real I
got any to hold on to these for a minute
because I hope they made a mistake cuz
he ripped me off so I hope he got ripped
on me he took you to the woods yet he
told me this was his plan and I hope you
didn't stick to it but it's plant lucky
and again I've never purchased cars
before didn't know that like you know
carts be worth about it junk eras all I
knew meeting for cars terrible don't do
it
not a good thing yeah I mean I'm gonna
hear complain paid 80 bucks apiece it's
offseason market uh cold right now no
I'm fine
he said you know hit season losses gonna
go off though go up to about 160 you
know I'll double my money on the stumble
back a little bit
yes he's right no way dude and now you
look at it if you're like bro like I'm
not saying come by bring a car but if
you wanted to
yeah good well if bro when it's not
about Gary because he was buying Lucas
from other places he made the right call
Luca I was pushing everybody hard that's
right I was pushing people hard to buy
the LeBron 4050 it's 7,500 if you want
if you want 10 like that's a real thing
there's no stock that's gone up more
during that time there's no real estate
investor like it's happening and I think
it's got a long way to go and by the way
we're all sitting here laughing at Luca
or marveling at Luke at 600 if Luca is
as good as I personally think he is and
does not get hurt I'd hate to see what
that card is worth on the next flip in
15 years where we go hard here for four
years then the market gets soft they all
go down 20 and 30% cuz your friend is
over and then it gets hot again in 15
years who the [ __ ] knows what I could be
yep they because all trucks ever yep
it's an opportunity card that I'm really
excited about good for you but that
means a B it's very important and I'm
sure that have you done this a good bit
so just to continue to reiterate to
people that are getting into the market
to do your freaking homework 50 hours
and also know that like if I saw like
the other day
Ronna coming in with nuts yes he's my
guy I live in Atlanta all about it
I thought someone's talking after after
my panel was too thin of heat so I was
in a 75 I was pumped I didn't Leonard
300 on sockets and I said hey I got my
money it's all good like people need to
know that I'm brother back to the looka
figure out your stress let me but you
can't
about the fact that the market went nuts
hey you double that like that you can't
beat me to it you're never gonna catch
any market at the top and to me if
you're smart there's so much opportunity
and by the way if Ronald goes 50/50
which he potentially has in him I mean
if I'm just listen I'm just talking
sports if Ronald you got fifty fifty and
became the first guy to do it
it's a thousand dollar card if he's the
first guy to do it
he did that 200 next year maybe two
you're after doesn't matter
listen it doesn't matter if you want to
flip them at a thousand if you're doing
what I'm doing which is your help you're
hoping in perpetuity that you're buying
people that sustain value you want to be
a little bit careful like to me reasons
to the event Lana and I'm walking in on
like this is crazy but also I got like
my book well I would have you to set an
initial look I agree flip flip flip flip
flip and I'll have a ton of cars there's
no net worth or whatever in cards but if
your crashes a lot five grand I mean to
your point here's one of the things for
me do you understand so I've bought how
many Ronald's tops the way ever now hi
guy I bought thirty three complete set
because back to educating my away I
missed it I wasn't I was going too fast
so I'm gonna get the updated thirty I
had the guide more no okay thirty to
forty updates right again not big
economics for me personally this is why
everybody's like these manipul enlike I
wish they knew you know it's not that
they're dumb it's just that they're
they're making hot takes without any
truth but they just know they're making
assumptions without knowing me as a
human being nor any of my truths of how
what I'm sitting on now here's why I'm
excited if you think I give a [ __ ] about
an Atlanta Braves game in September and
in the last twenty years I do not
if mr. Ronald goes into labor day with
51 home 41
and 39 and 39 steals I'm gonna be out of
my [ __ ] mind I'm not gonna miss on at
least a box score cuz I'm busy but I'm
gonna be fired up and then Lou's gonna
text me at 11:30 at night while I'm and
then I'm back in the you got it and that
brings happiness that's a that to me is
something that people are missing the
book the NBA Finals is the playoffs this
year are about to be 30x interesting to
me there are bloggers because I'm
excited I keep throwing back to you
y'all mentions you want you the PSA 9
that I was like dude no doubt like
literally I think it was three weeks ago
or a month ago I would like wire cuz I
got in right when the national happen I
got in I was like Ronald opinions my god
Atlanta I started my rah rah rah
I'm sitting like 70 raw yesterday make
that top report you know pop a little
more but here's the deal is that I was
like what was that I was buying cards
I'll throw the offseasons because
everything is super cheap and I don't
get it cuz I remember a price agreement
so like Wi-Fi get an encapsulated PSA 9
Rama Cunha for 20 ships for 25 ships and
then literally like release later it's
like 70 bucks 100 brother the mark the
market is no different than whether it's
cryptocurrency and guess what Bitcoin
was a good investment at this like here
this many years later when even though
it fluctuated no different than real
estate but from Mike pliers who's here
has done a lot of stuff in the Broadway
Market I'm sure when when [ __ ]
Hamilton first came out and the resale
value was super high everybody was
complaining and it hadn't even gotten
close to its height yet because it was
early if this is good old-fashioned
Americana supply and demand if I'm right
and I could be wrong and I've been wrong
before but [ __ ] I rarely am I mean the
market has already done what I said I
was gonna do two years ago but I still
think it's early man I really do think
it's early and do I think that creates
very high prices that become a
vulnerability in four years I do but I
think there's less of a vulnerability if
that's LeBron and Brady and
and if you're right about Luca or if tre
young does become Steph Curry and wins
two titles in Atlanta drop in 55 by
shooting from half-court you have to be
right sports cards will not disappear
off the face of the earth like the pet
rock they've been doing it for a hundred
years it's not going anywhere which ones
which grading companies which is a
people like one of the big debates right
now is is it PSA 9 or is it hoops PSA 10
I'm Luca is a Luca prism PSA 9
what's the bulb like I don't know are
the tens locking in so hard because
people want tens i think b gs is not as
popular as pc yeah you know PSA was
doing it longer but Beckett was back in
and if Beckett made the decision to go
ten instead of nine provide because even
do it now but even the PFA ninth of the
Athenians we're shooting us at forty
fifty I was still grabbing PFA bgs nine
point five yeah me too when I just right
up top I'm doing the same thing I've
been buying BBS night yeah to me it's
when I go deeper and I'm trying to buy
up inventory I've been going bgs nine
point five not PSA nine I could be wrong
I bought I bought Ronald I bought Ronald
complete sets because I didn't read
carefully and didn't buy tops update
then there's the holiday [ __ ] like I'm
getting educated to I'm excited about
losing this phone call is about me
losing I sold 60 Lucas for 60 bucks for
3,600 for 3,600 those same 60 Lucas are
now worth 36,000 that's a $32,000 l to
my [ __ ] mouth
[Music]
alright that's the biggest joke ever as
if like it's not like I'm running around
town saying you know you got to go hot
on some guy who like suck [ __ ] yeah
it's not really fun like when you're in
a city that has two superstars I have
also really big rush on column why did
these go in 20 attend every night he's a
good dude
I like John comments a lot here I like
John collee the problem is the problem
the problem is powered forwards
don't pop as much if you look at the R
and you're looking like right you deal
with you look at you look at the rant
like so I'm sorry I apologize you look
at Kevin Garnett you look at Tim Duncan
like the big men don't pop the way the
scores do but then again like John
Collins is his game is still developing
and he stood in threes to your point to
your point we're getting to the point
where even if you're a five you got to
shoot from three yeah so yeah evolution
okay and by the way something I brought
up here tonight and then in seven years
two founders really invent a grading
company that puts it through a [ __ ]
computer and it scans and no humans
there and no longer you worry about uh
somebody on the take or trimming their
brother this is a great way to recap
this whole night it's not about the
money it's about what you like to do and
what you're good at
I'm not good yeah twenty ten years ago
in rooms like Kerry you're so right
about face book into it you should start
a startup I'm like I don't do that I
don't got to use them I don't start a
technology company that grades cards I
make bets on stickers or SGC or or a
Jordan card that I think because it's
art will play today the hobby doesn't
like oversized cards I think it will I
could be wrong yeah I could be wrong you
know today I don't think the Hobby
worried right I mean the rock is more
famous than every [ __ ] athlete like
so there's just a lot of things are
where LeBron is for the next hundred
years he's there Jordan yeah my favorite
cards come on I'm my favorite cards to
buy right now or sixty one FLIR
basketball Oscar
Jerry West the logo will Chamberlain my
what what my my
my thesis I don't like anything I'm
unemotional it comes to this stuff
I like basketballs future you know I
like I like Netflix and kwibi and Amazon
Prime so I think a lot of documentaries
are coming I would argue that Pippin and
Rodman's rookies are about to go up
because a ten-part docu-series is coming
about the Bulls this summer and for a
lot of people they're gonna get educated
on how those players played and I think
Jordan rookies are gonna quadruple
because this could become cultural no
different than the Blind Side no
different than miracle and ice no
different than anything it takes one
thing nobody cared about star wars was I
was in high school and I was buying Star
Wars figures at garage sales for a
quarter and buying out everybody's
collection cuz I heard a rumor at a
baseball card store that Star Wars
movies were gonna come back and then all
those Star Wars figures that I bought
for a quarter started selling on eBay
for 20 bucks apiece my my thesis is that
basketball is the culture it's the same
reason I'm buying Pele's in the 50s and
60s I think that basketball soccer on
the upside and I think as we get deeper
into basketball culture this generations
Mickey Mantle's and Babe Ruth's actually
then become Wilt Chamberlain and Kareem
abdul-jabbar and then god forbid god
forbid the coolest Netflix documentary
is about Kareem or about Wilt or about
Jerry if a documentary comes out in a
year called the logo you got me if in 24
months at the prime of Netflix they come
out with a documentary called the logo
and it's Jerry West story and it gets
into the public consciousness and that
is in parallel with the white heat
moment of the sports card world which I
think it will be I think Jerry Westerby
cards can be 4x what they are now
because guess what there's a lot of
Lucas there is not a lot of 1961 Jerry
West rookie cards running around
whatever yeah it's why I think dr. J is
wildly interesting yeah so I just want
to say one thing Santa Claus is my dad
so MSU has a national oh I remember oh I
remember that was the best
I say what's up to your dad for me he's
gonna pass the crazy you know else is
crazy is the other day I put up
something on my Instagram story about
cars I've been doing a couple I have
liked it just for my friends goodbye
okay look I bought a Lucca Brady it's
worth 550 and I was like I didn't my
father mm thank you and this guy named
Arthur Leopold hopped into my BM she's
CEO of cameo he was like dude I was just
hanging out with Gary B and all I could
talk about was sports cars he's like
what's going on with that and I was like
dude if it's the move like I think it is
though thank you brother I wish you well
every night I'm wrapping up
I hope this brought some clarity some
value some information I'll be on social
answering questions in perpetuity I'm
excited about it I'm enjoying it if you
just want to collect raw cards of your
favorite athlete and that is an
enjoyment good news that's there for you
if you want to only collect classics and
put them away for 20 years I do think
that's a good move if you're excited
about making an entire bet on torres of
Vlad jr. or Tootsie sits high risk it
can be wild high reward I think for
people that bet on sports games that
that's a better use of their money so
that makes me happy there's just a
million [ __ ] ways to if you just want
to buy two cards just so you can enjoy
baseball cuz it's boring as [ __ ] for you
now because they haven't marketed well
that's a good idea if you just want to
enjoy the NBA Finals more and you decide
to look at who's gonna make the playoffs
and by the superstar of each team that's
a good idea or if you don't want to do
[ __ ] and you want to do like that one
caller and go into Pokemon or Magic the
Gathering or rare stickers I think
that's a good idea
or if you love like finding angles
whether that's a card that nobody
understands a genre that nobody
understands a grading company that you
think has potential there's a different
you know stickers soccer there's so many
ways to do it you're in charge not me
not [ __ ] everybody else and just wait
to see what happens next and don't blame
the sports card companies who are now
gonna be 10x the production of course we
have the next Jeff black Sierra panini
and tops and leaf and upper deck are not
in the business of
maintaining the hobby in a limited way
to make sure to supply and demand gets
up there in the business of selling
carts we're in the business of being
educated that prism this year is
probably four times the production of
prism the year before of course that's
what happened to her in a jungle back
Syria they were making millions because
millions were buying but then inevitably
once the interest wanes the people that
hired I don't know I do not know my
intuition is no I think a lot of people
like it's better than ever I'm like you
weren't there when there was no internet
video games were still far less of a big
deal than you think in 1987 there was a
Nintendo at scale but like it wasn't
like full time there was only 36
channels there was no internet there was
no Netflix sport every single kid in my
6th 7th and 8th grade class 89% of them
collected and flipped cards so I don't
think it's as big I do think there is
something else though because that is
the golden era much like if you look at
coins cars sports cards if you look at
sports cards golden era it was people
that grew up in the 50s that then had
money in the 70s that really drove that
market I do think you're seeing that now
people like me who couldn't afford [ __ ]
jack [ __ ] can now Ford stuffs are there
doing that so I think there's a lot of
variables but I don't think it's bigger
than it was in 86 to 93 and I think what
the card companies have done well is
they've started creating one of 10 super
premium product so there is some play
but I think to remind people if you were
wrong about Greg Vaughan or Mike
Greenwell or Jerome Walton or Bo Kimble
or Glen big baby Robinson or Eric Davis
like if they didn't go on to because I
thought our Tabas was gonna be really
amazed if he became Willie Mays those
carts would be or something like this is
about being right about players or it's
about gambling and pulling a very rare
card and you're allowed to do whatever
you want or kind of what I'm doing 80%
classic did the homework and look at the
last 50 years when the market gets
[ __ ] he'll go down 20 to 40% I won't
be pumped but I'm not gonna liquidate
then because I'll never expose myself
that I need the money and then when it
goes back up it will continue to pick up
the way they have anything else any
other like
tough questions I'm pumped at you asked
about the national SGC I continue to
talk the tops open II like there was
nothing more exciting maybe in my life's
history then when this happened me being
in a sports card that you can get out of
pack is still one of the great things
that ever happened to me oh so you did
yeah that was the best I continue to
like pound tops and panini every day
like hey you wanna do something with me
because I want to open up packs with me
and it's [ __ ] amazing I wasn't good
enough to be in sports so I never
thought that would be in my journey but
so that's fun so that's going on maybe
in seven years I buy an old brand I've
thought about that I went to sleep on my
public content but I was buying I was
bleeding under water because Boehner
media had a lot of things going on the
jet season always takes away my
attention yeah I love the National more
than breathing cuz I like being a dealer
it was the best moment of my life but I
do it once a year but you know but I go
to the Westchester show the other day
and like nobody like people don't know
and by the way tomorrow because of a
business opportunity or a family
situation or something else I may not be
able to tweet about sport you know me I
up and flow I can't have sustained heat
I get too bored I'm too interested in a
lot other [ __ ] but I've been buying the
whole time and I'll continue to
aggressively buying cuz I think it's a
good deal not because of my health or
cuz I love the sports card God's I don't
love anybody but my family and ever end
and jet fans and my team and 99.9
percent of my content is to let my
community who is not as fancy as these
car dealers that are mad at me who do
have only $800 the same audience that I
told to go to garage sales and buy
things for a dollar if I believe in my
heart that Lucas at $35 or underpriced
and I have a whole world of friends and
followers that are in college debt to
the tune of $70,000
and if they bought a hundred of them
because they didn't buy some dumb [ __ ]
like I tell them not to do or they saved
and stopped buying coffee and bought a
hundred of them they'd be out of debt
I'm not here to buy thirty [ __ ] a
Cunha and flip like what the [ __ ] the
matter with people of the millions I've
spent 90% of its go to sleep because I
think it's art I think this is the
[ __ ] $100,000 thing I do I believe it
in 21 years so I'm not flipping it at
the National you can rip me off we're
all so so much stuff cuz it's fun
I needed to care about baseball again so
I need the [ __ ] Soto's and Cooney ins
and I need that [ __ ] because I've been
waning and I don't want to lose in
fantasy baseball every year I want to
win wrestling's forever yeah I'm sorry
I'm not tweeting as much or as little or
I'm I can't win I don't tweet you're not
you disappeared I tweet too much you're
manipulate I'm not nobody's buying on my
behalf so if you're more than welcome to
see it you know cynicism [ __ ]
cynicism
it's a [ __ ] poison cynicism I'm not
judging how you're living your life you
want to collect raw cards from your
childhood I think that's good dog [ __ ]
you think it's amazing
knock yourself out Gary you must collect
jet players nope give a [ __ ]
zero folks that's not how I approach it
but if you want to collect bears cards
like it's your job I'm so happy for you
good news those will stay underpriced
you're so upset about manipulation good
news raw cards and your favorite players
will stay under price
and if their generational talents like
hey you got to make sure your bandwagon
like that kid if you're [ __ ] bandwagon
you just following LeBron and Zion
you're gonna get caught if you're a
hometown fan you'll probably okay plus
if you can't get to everything I think
Francisco Lindor is a [ __ ] big-time
player I haven't bought a thing I mean
looked up his cards yet
good good
see ya